an SCP Foundation researcher sits at a
table inside of a standard containment
cell these are often dangerous places to
be especially when the SCP you're
supposed to be studying is one that you
can't see the researcher is taking notes
unsure of exactly what is going to
happen next he can hear the sounds of
knives scraping behind of Flesh sizzling
and Searing from high heat he braces
himself as a burst of heat hits the back
of his head as if a fireball had erupted
an object floats through the air and
settles in front of him on the table
it's a plate of food and it looks
delicious it may surprise you to learn
that there is no rule that the SCP
Foundation must deal exclusively with
violent and vicious creatures not every
SCP held in containment shares the same
malevolence and contempt for Humanity as
SCP
682 or the world-ending threat posed by
the likes of SCP
2317 some perhaps perhaps not many but
some are benign and might even seem
outwardly friendly but you'd still be
taking a huge risk to assume that
anything contained by the SCP Foundation
is completely harmless such is the case
with SCP 5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this quasi
humanoid meaning it appears to have some
vaguely human features is held in an
airtight cell that is regularly checked
by Foundation Personnel on a bi-weekly
basis SCP 5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with SCP 5031 is not
being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need food it does still hunt and
consume anything it encounters human or
otherwise avoiding being eaten is hard
enough with creatures that can actually
be seen But like so many other creatures
the foundation keeps contained SCP 5031
has developed an almost perfect def
defense mechanism which is when observed
it will literally cease to exist some
might choose to refer to this as a
Quantum lock however it is worth noting
that traces left by SCP 5031 still
remain observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by SCP 531 still exist when the
SCP itself does
not naturally this makes both avoiding
the creature and capturing it using
camera is difficult however when SCP 50
31's existence ceases it still casts a
shadow from this researchers have been
able to determine several of the
creatures physical traits based on its
silhouette it has been deduced that SCP
531 levitates about half a meter above
ground level Sports an abnormally small
necklace head a top and elongated torso
approximately 1.9 M long with three sets
of spinley lower arms that Branch
outwards using these arms and its
Loosely hanging body SCP 531 will lower
itself to hunt any human or animal that
draws near to it and uses the blade
likee tail to cut up
food perhaps the most interesting facet
of SCP 55031 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes are the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researcher Stanley
Huxtable appalled by the conditions that
the creature was being kept in huxel
took over the role of HCL supervisor for
SCP 5031 having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic towards the
creature listening to its screams from
inside its iron containment unit huxel
devised a series of tests to introduce
SCP 531 to various different stimuli as
a way to better understand the creature
and hopefully keep it contained in a way
that didn't seem to cause so much
suffering it's worth remembering that
the SCP Foundation makes its mission to
be cold not cruel in performing their
duties to protect protect normality and
many of the researchers and staff are
just as capable of having empathy for
creatures as you might for a stray
animal at a
shelter the first of huxtable's tests
involved installing speakers an SCP 5031
cell through which a variety of
different ambient and popular pieces of
music were played to see if they had any
effect on reducing the creature's stress
by judging SCP 5031 stress levels based
on how much it screamed when compared to
normal Huxtable was able to determine
how to best use music to calm the
creature SCP 531 seemed to convey higher
levels of stress when listening to
morning Forest deep Grotto and seaside
Paradise Ambience as well as the best of
late 60s British rock band Jeth rotol
however the best of Mozart Ena kiss and
Ben Folds produc dramatically different
results decreasing SCP 531s apparent
stress following this test senior
researcher huxel compiled a playlist
featuring SCP 531 favorite music
over time the stress reducing effects of
Music on SCP 5031 seemed to decrease but
keeping the playlist on shuffles seemed
to keep the creature consistently calmer
than it had been
previously the next test involved
introducing inanimate objects into SCP
50 31's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected when a softball was thrown into
the enclosure SCP 5031 immediately
sliced the ball in two with its tail in
one swift motion a similar result
occurred when researchers threw the
creature a basketball which was quickly
punctured and sliced open by SCP 5031
tail its stress levels first seemed to
diminish when the creature was offered a
bowling ball which it rolled around the
enclosure and then later knocked it
against a second bowling ball however
when one of the balls chipped rendering
it unable to roll properly SCP 5031
stress increased dramatically until a
replacement was offered researcher huxel
noted that SCP p531 seemed to possess a
similar level of motor skills to an
average human toddler with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to
match next when given the choice between
two food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure SCP 5031 seemed to gravitate
towards higher quality food most notably
favored cooked rotisserie chickens over
animal carcasses it even chose this
option over aive chicken using its tail
to cut its food into more manageable
bite-sized portions rather than ripping
it meet with its hands or teeth like
many of its fellow
scps researcher huxel recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though SCP 5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive providing the creature
with food of a better quality marginally
reduced its
stress senior researcher huxel next
attempted to test SCP 531 coexistence
with other living
subjects each time making sure that the
creature had been adequately fed to
avoid any any unseemly
incidents first a life chicken was
introduced SCP 531 rolled its bowling
ball at high speed towards the chicken
increasing both its and the chicken's
stress levels and inadvertently killing
the chicken in the
process when a second chicken was
introduced SCP 5031 gently rolled a
basketball towards it but ceased any
further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball next
to be introduced into the enclosure was
a blindfolded d-class staff member who
was in instructed to sit down and roll
the basketball towards SCP 5031 after
doing so for several minutes the
creature began to approach the d-class
subject who was instructed to remove
their blindfold to Cease the creatures
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
huxel had another class D engage in a
game of catch with SCP 5031 while facing
away from the
creature this test proceeded
successfully and Senior researcher huxel
remarked how SCP 531s motor skills
skills were improving albeit gradually
and with some gentle encouragement
through huxtable's tests the creature
was
learning the next test focused on
teaching SCP 531 linguistic symbols
utilized LCD displays and buttons
connected to a food dispenser One
display showed an image of a rock and
the other an image of a rotisserie
chicken after some brief probing SCP 531
was quickly able to understand that
pressing the button under the correct
display would dispense a rotis chicken
for it to eat the creature was later
able to adapt when the following day the
screen displays and materials dispensed
were swapped and then later set to swap
at random intervals when additional Rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image SCP 55031 was able to
determine which station dispensed
chicken through a process of elimination
whenever the functions and displays were
swapped SCP 55031 would find whichever
displayed the word chicken to receive
its food the Final Phase of this test
presented SCP 55031 with a single
station displaying the word chicken but
with a button that would remain inactive
unless the creature spelled out the same
word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with after some
initial confusion and frustrations as to
why the button would not dispense food
when pressed SCP 55031 was able to
assemble the word correctly not only
activating the button and dispensing
food but proving to researcher hux that
the creature was capable of learning
language huxel continued to test the
creature encouraging it to spell words
using lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing SCP 5 31's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received senior
researcher huxel observed that SCP 55031
was gradually learning to sing albeit
nonverbally as well as to juggle with
its six hands and was even communicating
its food preferences and Dish pairings
later another class D D 52125 was
introduced to SCP 531s enclosure to Aid
in further testing through d521 25's
instructions the creature quickly
learned to draw using crayons and
created artworks depicting itself its
Newfound friend d521 125 researcher
hustable a cat and a rotisserie
chicken SC cp50 31's new creative side
didn't stop there though as the creature
quickly learned to play chopsticks in
only 2 days once a piano was introduced
into the enclosure SCP 55031 even
managed to start creating its own
original admittedly crude
compositions next a spice rack was
placed inside the creature's cell and D
52125 demonstrated how to season meat
this proved to be SCP 531s new favorite
hobby as it spent the next 3 days
experimenting with different
combinations of foods and spices using
its letter blocks to request more more
more more garlic powder interestingly
the creature only created artwork or
music when D 52125 was present but
seemed to thoroughly enjoy its
experimentation with food when left
alone following this development senior
researcher huxel devised a new test for
SCP 531 providing the creature with
cooking utensils and using D 52125 to
demonstrate 5031 was shown how to
prepare a variety of different dishes
from hamburgers and Tacos to Mongolian
beef steak clam chowder and peritols in
addition to a small peanut allergy this
eighth test revealed SCP 5031 to be a
phenomenal Chef possessing culinary
skills far beyond the average person the
creature quickly and enthusiastically
embraced its Newfound talents concocting
its very own brand new recipes with d
52125 even volunteering to be the first
to taste test 5031 dishes it was shortly
after this test that SCP 5031 spoke its
very first word and it should come as no
surprise that the word was salt
naturally senior researcher huxel was
very proud of the progress the creature
had made with its development the final
test almost seemed to be what the
creature was born for over the course of
2 months SCP 531 was tasked with
creating a full three course meal which
would then be served to Foundation staff
for Thanksgiving SCP 55031 not only Rose
to the test but exceeded all of
researcher huxtable's expectations
creating a meal that even Gordon Ramsay
would be hard pressed to find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric next came a
beautiful duck coni glazed luxuriously
with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compost paired with
a sight of butternut squash nooki and
served on a bit of kale seasoned with
truffle salt the grand finale of the
Exquisite meal was a cassava pie
for dessert complemented with the finest
French vanilla ice cream and a maple
hazelnut syrup an SCP 5031 didn't stop
there the creature also debuted one of
its original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
SCP 5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher huxel but the
entire Foundation staff as a fitting end
to the creature's taale Huxtable
reported that during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created SCP 5031 stress
levels reduced
entirely new Kinder containment measures
that would keep 5031 safer but also far
more contented were submitted for
approval perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that SCP 5031 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world instead SCP 5031 is a gentle if a
little frightening at first creature
that just requires careful and
considered guidance instead of a cold
iron cage and round-the-clock arm guards
through testing senior researchers
Stanley huxel and his fellow Foundation
staff were not only able to help the
creature develop but also found what
makes it tick and not just for the
purposes of containing it instead it is
hoped that SCP 531 creativity and flare
for culinary and musical masterpieces
can continue to thrive and grow under
the proud watch of researcher hux think
back to your childhood and ask yourself
what was the most pain you've ever felt
while growing up as we develop our
understanding of pain evolves according
to our different experiences the older
we get the injuries we suffered as
children like a scraped knee or a bee
sting rarely caus us the same level of
distress as they used to of of course
when you are young and unfamiliar with
sensations of pain what you really need
in that moment straight after you've
fallen off your bike or tripped playing
soccer is someone to pick you back up
and give your Source spot a kiss perhaps
you even need a bowl of warm soup to
comfort you luckily for you SCP 348 is
exactly that while many of the anomalies
held in containment by the SCP
Foundation have earned the uid or
inFAMOUS ker class designations SCP 348
is one of the few considered to be safe
both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
eldrich Abomination From Another
Dimension spreading its influence in our
world through mimic stimuli nor is it a
recording of a basketball game in which
all the players and Spectators are
trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the Garden of Eden to put it simply
SCP 348 is a bowl a white ceramic Bowl
the kind you would find almost anywhere
in the world it may even look
indistinguishable from the one in your
kitchen cabinet of course SCP 348 is
hardly as ordinary as it outwardly
appears to be and it certainly isn't the
only inanimate object that the
foundation keeps safely stored away the
key thing that differentiates SCP 348
from most other anomalies is how
genuinely harmless it is it's Ness
properties do not cause injury to any
individual that interacts with it nor
does this bowl have any adverse effects
on the world around it SCP 348 cannot
bend or reshape reality it does not
cause the person eating from it to have
premonitions of their own death and
using it certainly does not manifest a
contract making entity at the opposite
side of the table so what makes this
bowl in any way anomalous what about it
categorizes it as an SCP and not just a
harmless piece of fine C Rockery well
why don't we start with how SCP 348 was
first discovered some time ago the SCP
Foundation was made aware of rumors
surrounding the child living in an
unknown part of the world according to
the intelligence gathered by the
foundation this child seemed to possess
some sort of healing ability or at least
this is what rumors suggested upon
further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as SCP 348 this is not to
say that the bowl has any inherently
Supernatural healing properties and it
doesn't impart any regenerative power to
those that eat from it either it does
heal in a certain sense but not in the
way you're probably imagining when the
SCP Foundation recovered SCP 348 there
were no markings on it indicating where
the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand painted around both the inside and
outside of SCP 348 the ceramic surface
also bore the Chinese letters Shang
shini which translates to the phrase
thinking of you the child that first
discovered it found the ceramic Bowl in
the Attic of their home the child's
parents were both full-time workers and
seemed to be somewhat neglectful of
their child although they refused to
comment on this but according to the
findings of the SCP Foundation the child
had come to rely on SCP 348 deciding to
further investigate the anomalous
properties of SCP 348 the foundation
began testing it given that the child
who first discovered the bull had relied
upon it tests involve Foundation
researchers presenting certain children
to SCP 348 and observing the results so
was this bowl haunted perhaps harboring
some malicious Spirit or entity that
sought to corrupt these children maybe
even healing them in order to somehow
use them as a vessel to break into our
world no and while it may have not
healed in any overt or expected way it
did heal in at least a metaphorical
sense if presented with an injured child
sporting any form of minor ailment such
as a cut or a running nose SCP 348 fills
with warm soup and yes that's right we
said soup what kind you may ask well
that seems to vary sometimes it is
tomato soup other times it might be
chicken noodle soup while the
ingredients used in the soups are often
different there are notable
consistencies to our SCP 348 heels if
anyone between the ages of 4 years old
and 18 years old sits down in front of
the blue flowered Bowl then SCP 348 will
fill with soup numerous young test
subjects brought in by the foundation to
eat from this particular bowl of soup
have reported that they enjoyed their
meal usually finishing the entire Bowl
when permitted to by research staff many
of the injured children that were tested
have stated that the soup they eat from
SCP 348 reminds them of their parents
cooking these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises some even claimed that even
though they were in a room all alone
they didn't feel lonely when they were
eating the soup and all the anomalous
properties don't end after a child
finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a
message often some brief words of
reassurance or Comfort these messages
materialize on the inside rim of of the
bowl and seem to be specifically
tailored to the subject that is just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on SCP 348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bowl refills with more
soup one test of SCP 348 saw a little
girl age8 and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according
to a background screening made by
research Personnel the girl lived with
her biological parents and apparently
had a good relationship with both her
mother and her father when SCP 348
filled with soup for her the girl took
almost half an hour to finish eating and
afterwards reported that she felt her
sore throat get better as she aimed by
the end of the meal this test subject
remarked that she felt completely normal
in this instance no message appeared
within the bowl another child was
brought in to continue the testing of
SCP 348 this time a boy of 10 unlike the
previous test this boy was not on good
terms with his parents and often argued
with them at the time of testing the boy
had sustained several minor bruises the
result of a small accident that occurred
while the boy had been out riding his
bike much like the little girl this
subject ate the soup that SCP 348
presented him with this time though the
bowl offered a message to the boy the
lettering found on the ceramic surface
of SCP 348 simply read R don't forget to
brush messages also appeared when an
11-year-old boy with a slight cold ate
soup from the bowl this child had been
adopted by a foster family and after
eating from SCP 348 he saw the message
I'm glad you're happy appear another
young test subject a boy age six had a
similar experience in this instance the
child had several scrapes and scratches
from playing with his friends his
parents had divorced and he was living
with his mother at the time of testing
this time SCP 348 message to this boy
read I'm sorry son a 7-year-old girl
suffering from a cough was brought in
before SCP 348 she had lost her father
to a traffic accident some time before
testing commenced and received the
message I love you after finishing her
soup further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from SCP 348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases testing
SCP 348 on older candidates still
revealed messages although the words
seemed to be faded not the clear handp
painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of SCP 348
much like it had before the bowl filled
with soup and the woman ate as with some
of the younger subjects a key aspect of
This Woman's background seemed to be
what triggered the message to appear
specifically she admitted to being on
bad terms with her mother and father the
woman explained that she had opted to
live on her own isolating herself from
her family in fact she even described
having rejected an offer her father made
to her many years earlier refusing some
Career Training that he was willing to
give in order to help her secure a job
when she finished the soup one word
appeared in the bowl why another woman
who was 40 years old was also brought in
for the SCP 348 testing much like the
previous subject she had moved away from
home and became arange from her parents
over the years but unlike the previous
test this woman had taken it upon
herself to not only send money to her
parents but also arrang senior care for
both as well prior to testing her father
had died peacefully of natural causes
after spending his last days in the care
that this woman had paid for as the
woman ate the soup from the bowl she
remarked about its apparently bitter
taste but also described her meal as
fulfilling after she had finished the
words thank you appeared with an SCP 348
one other adult subject that produced a
noticeable result from SCP 348 was a
40-year-old male the results of this
test appeared to be the most distinctly
different from any previous adult or
Child by now researchers working for the
SCP Foundation had determined that
familial history seemed to play an
important role in the outcome of any
interaction with SCP 348 and this
individual was certainly different to
most the man in question had murdered
his father roughly a year before the
testing took place he began the test
with SCP 348 while Afflicted with aches
in his back after one Taste of the soup
that appeared in the Bowl before him the
murderer was immediately repulsed he
complained about the taste refusing to
eat any more from CP 348 shortly after
the man began to experience severe
stomach pain the potentially poisonous
soup was disposed of but SCP 348
immediately filled with saltwater which
took 3 hours to disappear from the bowl
despite conducting numerous tests with
subjects of all ages and ailments the
SCP Foundation researchers have so far
been unable to determine the origins of
the messages that sometimes appear in
SCP 348 some are theorize because of the
the family histories of some children
and adults tested that the words somehow
come from the father of whoever eats the
soup since even when a subject's father
is alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of SCP 348 to provide Comfort to
small children dealing with pain both
inside and out after all isn't providing
Comfort what a good bowl of soup
anomalous or not is best at being a
video archist for the SCP Foundation is
one of the easiest jobs in the entire
organization you're responsible for
viewing every tape found in the field
every interview with an anomaly and
every event log recorded by a mobile
Task Force if something passes your desk
that means the foundation's going to
want its contents viewed transcribed and
the original Source footage stored for
preservation compared to the doctors
working tirelessly to push their
research to the boundaries of understood
science and field agents risking their
lives elsewhere your job of lounging in
an air conditioned room sitting at a
computer and watching videos all day
seems pretty appealing at least on paper
it does when you take into account just
what it is you'll be transcribing the
Grim realities present in all Foundation
careers starts to emerge in your
deceptively cushy office gig it's no
secret that the foundation's visual Lo
describe unspeakable Horrors within
disgusting body alterations gory details
and terrifying imagery are Mainstays of
foundation files most are never
conscious of the fact that every log
that's been written out had to have been
viewed by someone in the first place
those blank redacted areas where your
imagination has to fill in the details
somewhere someone in the foundation had
to describe that sensitive information
in the first place that Gruesome Kill
and attack task force report the visual
archivist saw the footage before they
wrote it out sure your job might be to
watch the foundation's home movies all
day but due to the sheer amount of
visual materials the foundation needs to
transcribe and catalog you'll be on
average seeing far more Horrors than the
typical researcher or Task Force member
instead of being assigned to one or two
projects at a time you'll witness an
infinite slew of footage from across the
foundation's history you'll just be
viewing all of the horror from a
distance behind a screen after the fact
but you don't need to be told that
you're a professional hardboiled
grizzled veteran of the foundation you
watch hours of footage a day transcribe
it archive it and send it out to be
inserted in the various articles and
files in the foundation database you've
lived through countless Task Force
missions observed endless testing logs
and seen everything from unimaginable
entities to the bloodiest events ever
taken place it used to to keep you up at
night but at this point you're
desensitized to almost anything the
world can throw at you maybe that's why
you were the foundation's latest choice
to transcribe the footage recovered from
the site of SCP
6670 you'd heard the stories a series of
tapes the other archists were flat out
refusing to transcribe due to sheer
disgust and horror they'd been passed
down the line two or three times and now
they came to you in a box of literal VHS
tapes labeled with a strip of tape that
read SCP 6670 recovered media you didn't
doubt that whatever was on these was
intense since it was enough to get a few
Foundation archivists to pass something
that rarely happens but you were sure
they weren't anything you couldn't
handle you inspect the box for a
manifest paper to see if you can gain
any other information about the tanks
most of the time the varying parts of
the foundation's research is kept
heavily discernible from one another the
right hand never knows what the left is
doing so getting any further context to
the footage you're about to review is
often times necessary but the paper
inserted on top of the box doesn't
reveal much it reads footage recovered
from the discovery site of SCP
6670 containment site 886 Detroit
Michigan that's about as much as you're
going to get but at least it's something
you take the tape that says first on it
and and pop it into the VCR yeah you had
to dust off that old dinosaur just for
this the real anomaly is that it still
works after all these years the first
tape is overlaid with a title that takes
up the entirety of the screen happy
birthday Gemma 1988 it reads the camera
pans to a small infant laying down on a
cushion you can tell from the brief
glimpses of the background that the
house is dilapidated poorly held
together not the conditions a child
should be raised in but an unfortunate
reality that some face the baby stares
at the camera wiggling and making
adorable baby noises you wonder if this
is Gemma the birthday girl herself your
thoughts are confirmed by the camera
holder who plays with and tickles Gemma
celebrating her birthday the camera
holder asked the baby to smile for mommy
which the little Gemma gleefully does of
course the one holding the camera is
gemma's Mother and the two are cele
celebrating her first birthday the rest
of the tape is ordinary with Gemma and
her mother playing and laughing together
her mother sings Happy Birthday to her
and the recording stops well that wasn't
so bad you think to yourself in fact
taking into account most of the stuff
that passes your desk that was pretty
good but that was only the first tape
you're intrinsically drawn to the next
one wondering how this could possibly
Inspire so much fear in the others who
watched it second tape The Shot opens up
with a woman dressed in a slightly
tattered sewn together formal attire
she's filming herself standing before a
mirror the title reads job interview
practice tape after the title disappears
she begins talking to herself she
reveals her name Melanie Jamie G Parker
and acts as if she's applying to a job
specifically to an internship at the
Walter media broadcast company you can
tell from the sound of her voice that
this is gemma's Mother Melanie's mock
interview proceeds slowly she's visibly
apprehensive chokes over her words and
seems to be in great distress Melanie
mentions that she turned 18 the other
day and that she's interested in
applying for a job as a news reporter
still she can't get the words out
properly stuttering and hesitating she's
clearly distracted by something off
camera Midway through her rehearsal the
sound of high-pitched crying is heard
it's the baby Melanie assures Gemma that
she's coming and leans over to hit the
button to stop the recording before
rushing off to calm down the crying
child again nothing horrible you think
it's difficult to watch someone so young
struggle with the challenges of
motherhood but it hasn't made you lose
your lunch or anything you take out the
third tape pop it in and see what
happens next another title a letter to
my family cut this seems like it was
intended to be thrown out the picture
comes in showing a crying Melanie
sitting on the edge of her bed in a
white gown sniffling up her tears
Melanie delivers a message intended to
be viewed by her family you learn that
her relationship with them is unstable
and that Melanie has been on her own for
months potentially longer she musters
out an apology to her parents saying
that she's sorry about everything for a
party for stealing their money she
continues to cry but tells them that she
wants them to know that she's sorry and
that she loves them she she addresses
her sister's caring attitude and her
mother's smile but is hesitant to
compliment her father she reveals that
she hasn't spoken to them in 2 years but
she can't go any longer she's barely
been able to afford basic necessities
and despite applying for as many jobs as
she could she hasn't landed one her
personal savings are almost depleted and
she can't sleep at night gemma's getting
bigger a lot bigger than any girl should
be at two she's rapidly outgrowing her
clothes and Melanie's unable to provide
her with the love and care that she
needs she's halfway through saying that
she wants her parents to take custody of
Gemma but she stops she can't get
herself to admit it she stares at the
camera shakes her head and begins
cursing Melanie's voice gets louder and
she vly defends her decision to keep
Gemma for herself she's not subjecting
herself to her family who she clearly
despises Melanie continues to lash out
against her family saying that that
she's tired of them and that they will
never find her and Gemma she's visibly
shaking her voice unstable Melanie's
made her decision gemma's staying with
her she makes a statement you should
have seen how happy Gemma and I were how
nice life is out here the sun's so much
brighter there's no no fighting no
screaming no
crying I took my daughter and I left all
of you
and I am happy in the background gemma's
crying is heard again from another room
Melanie drain looks in the distance
surprised to hear that she's awake she
wipes the tears from her eyes and
assures Gemma that her mother will be
right there she forgets to turn the
camera off and rushes out of the room
for the rest of the tape lasting nearly
2 hours in duration Melanie calms Gemma
holding her and assuring her that she's
safe eventually the camera's battery
gives out and the recording stops
so far it's definitely upsetting to see
but you haven't encountered anything
anomalous yet maybe it's the fourth tape
that will shed some light on what's
going on here you put it in and prepare
for the worst this tape Cuts in
immediately without a title Gemma and
Melanie are playing together in
Melanie's bedroom what she said about
gemma's growth is two she's only two but
she stands at 4 ft tall with long and
disheveled blonde hair Gemma runs across
the bedroom making noises and pretending
to be an airplane Melanie for once
doesn't seem to be stressed though she
looks visibly tired the sound of a phone
ringing is heard in the background
Melanie immediately snaps out of her
happy attitude and runs off to answer it
while she talks on the phone Gemma is
seen peering into a small hole in the
wall of the bedroom she then moves off
screen while Melanie is talking on the
phone Gemma tries to get her mother's
attention when Melanie hangs up she
notices that she doesn't see her
daughter anywhere and begins frantically
searching Gemma answers her voice coming
from inside the hole in the wall Melanie
tries to go her child from outside the
wall but Gemma doesn't listen eventually
she hears a loud snap and then a scream
Melanie panics moving her head into the
hole Gemma cries screaming that she's in
pain and that she hurts something
Melanie tells her that she'll get help
and desperately tries not to panic she
runs offscreen and for 15 minutes all
that's heard is Gemma crying Melanie
returns with a young man who would later
be identified as her neighbor John Bates
he carries a rope Melanie directs bits
to a hole in the wall the two are
clearly familiar with one another and
Melanie assures Gemma that Mr JN is
going to help her out of the hole Bates
kneels on the floor and inserts his head
into the wall feeding the Rope inside
the hole on the count of three they tell
Gemma to grab the rope and they'll pull
seconds pass without a response and
suddenly Bates feels a tug she's
grabbing the Rope Melanie and Bates pull
together hoping to lift Gemma out of
wherever she fell but the girl won't
move she continues to cry saying that
she's stuck and neither Bates nor
Melanie can get her to budge Melanie who
is now crying assures Gemma that they'll
get her out while Bates is more
reluctant Bates tells her that they
aren't going to be able to get her out
by themselves and the two begin to argue
loudly they agree to call the fire
department after all they're specialized
in getting people out of confined spaces
Bates tries calling but the lines are
full meanwhile Melanie continues to lose
hope Bates insists that they have to
call 911 but Melanie knows that she
doesn't have enough to cover medical
costs and if they discover the living
conditions that gemma's been in they'll
surely take her child away the two
continue to argue bit suggests that
Melanie phones her family which is the
ultimate breaking point for her from off
screen you can hear a struggle the sound
of a cup board opening and then baits
hitting the floor 30 minutes of silence
follow when Melanie returns she's caked
in dirt grease and blood what happened
was evident Melanie sticks her head
inside the hole in the wall and assures
Gemma that her mother will take care of
her the next tape pulls you in the title
displays happy birthday Gemma
1991 you recognize that the video is
being taken from inside the wall there's
a small lava lamp and a cupcake with a
candle in front of Gemma who lays prone
on the ground she's more pale than
before and looks to be about 5 ft tall
now and her shoulders Encompass the
length of the space from behind the
camera Melanie sings to her and Gemma
blows out the candle the recording Stops
Another tape happy birthday Gemma
1993 gemma's looking visibly ill her
eyes droop she smiles tiredly and her
body seems to be larger than the space
it's confined to a cake sits in front of
her with five candles Melanie sings to
her again the 1997 birthday tape is even
worse Gemma is about 7 ft tall and her
face encompasses the entire hole with no
discernable head Melanie sings to Gemma
who just wants to eat her cake the sound
of gemma's Bones clinking and cracking
as her body contorts to the tight space
is heard the next tape is unlabeled but
the foundation determined it to be
recorded around 2001 Melanie sits
outside the door to her bedroom sobbing
her bedroom is entirely inaccessible
behind the door the cracking of Bones is
heard throughout the house she's singing
happy birthday to Gemma who is unseen
gemma's voice can be heard begging for
food another crack this time from the
ceiling dust Falls from above the house
is giving out Gemma screams that she is
in pain and that she doesn't want to
fall the cracking gets louder and before
Melanie can finish singing she's taken
back by the horror of the situation
Gemma begs for her mother to help her
and that her back hurts the ceiling's
about to give out any second and
suddenly it does the camera tips showing
a ceiling full of cracks which gives out
over the next few seconds Melanie
screams that she'll catch Gemma but she
is simply too big her form is revealed a
block of barely human skin and tissue
shaped into a square Mass due to being
confined to the walls for years you
can't tell that the entity before you is
still human and most of all an injured
scared child gemma's anomalous growth
when confined to such a small space over
a long period of time resulted in this
Gemma falls to the floor crushing
Melanie in the process for the remaining
4 hours of the tape Gemma sifts and
struggles all while crying out for her
mother the tape stops disturbed by the
content you know you're going to feel
sick transcribing these tapes you check
the corresponding database file for SCP
6670 and hopes you can access it
thankfully it's within your clearance
and all is illuminated when you read
what's already there SCP 6670 is Gemma
described as a large amorphous entity
made of Flesh tissue and contorted bones
SCP 6670 is confined to a small house in
Detroit Michigan where it's been
contained on site with a concrete Wall
constructed around the home SCP 6670 was
discovered following the recording of
the tape when passers by outside the
house described the structure as
breathing after which containment
measures were implemented and research
began the only access point to SCP 6670
is through the doorway outside the
bedroom as most of the House's structure
is either destroyed or taken up by SCP 6
670s Mass x-ray scans revealed that SCP
6670 spine is extremely contorted and is
assumed to have grown along the
dimensions of the home with puberty
assumed to have accelerated the growing
process SCP 6670 is largely immobile and
is believed to be hibernating its
intelligence seems to be roughly
equivalent to a small child inside the
home the tapes were found and the file
describes them as a waiting
transcription which is your job beneath
the section intended for your work is an
event log transcribed by Personnel
working on site with SC SCP
6670 the entity after remaining immobile
for so long had eventually moved the log
read as follows the entity rolled in
front of the camera where its mouth
could be seen it's surrounded by several
strings of Rotting Flesh and caked with
blood the teeth are rotten consistent
with typical patterns of tooth decay a
clump of black hair clings to the side
of its lower lip SCP 6670 is heard
speaking the camera registers the sound
as similar to Mama I'm hungry its voice
is that of a young girl you're taken
back by the graphic bodily alteration
described when the realization hits you
that you're going to have to watch these
tapes multiple times over to ensure
proper transcription but then one other
thing stands out a clump of black hair
on SCP 667s lip but Gemma had blonde
hair and then it hits you you know that
you'll be in for many sleepless nights
after this is all said and done there
was nothing out of the ordinary about
Timmy Mason like a lot of healthy
8-year-old boys Timmy liked to go on
little adventures in and around his
neighborhood and now that summer
vacation had finally rolled around he
had more time than ever to explore but
during one particularly hot day Timmy
suddenly realized that he was exhausted
the heat was beginning to get to him and
he'd forgotten to pack a water bottle
all he had was a couple of dollars and a
handful of quarters rattling around in
his pocket he was considering heading to
a nearby corner store and purchasing a
drink when he first heard the music it
was a tinny rendition of Pop goost the
weasel playing in The Distance
underscored by the rumbling of an engine
Timmy's face lit up this could only mean
one thing an ice cream truck just in
time he ran in the direction of the
sounds not wanting to miss out on the
cool sweet relief from the intense
summer heat but when the ice cream truck
suddenly rounded a corner and came into
view Timmy felt a Pang of anxiety it
didn't look like most of the ice cream
trucks he had seen driving around his
neighborhood in Prior Summers it was
shoddy an older more boxy model with
peeling white paint but it was so hot
out that Timmy felt he couldn't afford
to be picky if he wanted to cool off the
ice cream truck came to a noisy stop and
Timmy ran over when he reached the side
of the truck he noticed some other
strange details there was no serving
hatch in the back of the truck the
closest thing was a thin dark groove cut
into the driver's side door a door that
seemed almost drawn onto the side of the
truck rather than a door that looked
like it could actually open how could
the driver get in and adding to the
strangeness there was no menu on the
truck either typically on your friendly
neighborhood ice cream truck you'd find
a colorful collection of all the Frozen
and treats you could buy along with how
much they'd cost you but not here Timmy
guled nervously he knew something was
wrong here but for some reason he
couldn't seem to pull himself away he
cleared his throat forced a polite smile
and said can I get a green popsicle
please there was a strange rumbling
noise inside the ice cream truck
suddenly the slot in the door opened a
little wider and a long green popsicle
and a plastic wrapper emerged it came
with a small piece of paper with $5 .75
in loose scratchy handwriting on it
Timmy regarded the note with suspicion
and said that he was sorry but he didn't
have
$575 something inside the truck began
rumbling again louder this time more
aggressive while the truck growled from
within Timmy noticed something else was
wrong his popsicle was no ordinary
popsicle it was a dead snake
straightened out and frozen solid Timmy
screamed and dropped the so-called
popsicle he turned and began to run but
it was already too late the slot behind
him yawned open fully and a rusty
spring-loaded chain fired out like a
harpoon on the end of this chain was a
large snapping bear trap which quickly
latched onto Timmy's left leg the chain
yanked and pulled him backwards dragging
him ever closer to the darkened crevice
in the truck store moments later he was
pulled inside and the hatch closed
behind him his screams were muffled and
then overpowered entirely by the
rumbling Within soon after there was
silence and finally the cheerful tune of
Pop ghost the weasel began to play once
more the truck drove away prepared to
serve its frozen Delights to another
child somewhere anywhere not long after
Timmy was reported missing another young
boy bought a scoop of strawberry ice
cream in a waffle cone from the same
truck the boy's mother was horrified to
find that this alleged ice cream was
full of what seemed like blood and raw
meat lab test later confirmed that this
gory ice cream was a perfect genetic
match for poor missing Timmy Mason it
didn't take long for the SCP Foundation
to get involved seeing as mysterious
horrifying deaths like this one were
often the first sign of an anomaly's
presence in the area and they were able
to quickly track down and isolate the
Rogue ice cream truck this wasn't
especially difficult for the agents
assigned to the case since it literally
announced its presence with loud
obnoxious music well it was easy to find
the ice cream truck soon designated SCP
1386 did however prove to be more
difficult to contain than they first
imagined when a mobile task force
attempted to engage the truck in hopes
of apprehending it an earsplitting siren
began to blast from the truck's
undercarriage this caused catastrophic
inter ear damage to everyone involved
incidentally it's now believed that the
reason the ice cream truck engaged in
this defensive Behavior had nothing to
do with the fact the mobile task force
was armed but rather because of what
they weren't carrying it appears that
SCP 1386 doesn't turn on its siren
because of danger but when it detects
that someone is approaching it who isn't
carrying any money eventually the
foundation was able to trick the ice
cream truck into containment luring it
into a fake walled off neighborhood
where it could drive its rounds
constantly without the risk of
encountering civilians all those who had
previous encounters with the ice cream
truck were given amnestic treatment and
SCP 1386 was finally officially
contained but while it had been taken
off the streets the foundation's work
was only just beginning it was time for
research to commence the first key
discoveries that aided in the
investigation involve the factors that
are required for SCP 1386 to even serve
its subjects in the first place as the
previously mentioned mobile task force
learned you need to approach the truck
with at least $2 in cash to be
absolutely sure that it won't turn your
ears inside out the truck also Prov
proves to be extremely Adept at reading
human emotions and refuses to serve
anyone who doesn't appear happy with
these requirements now known the
foundation felt prepared to finally make
some orders first they sent in a pair of
level three researchers each of them
requested a delicious cookies and cream
flavored smoothie the truck pushed both
Smoothies Out of the slot in its door
one marked with the letter M and the
other with the letter g a handwritten
receipt with a price of
$4.89 written on it they paid the the
price and the transaction ended without
incident the smoothies were apparently
pretty good too next one of the
researchers returned perhaps longing for
another taste of SCP 1386 is wonderful
ice cream this time he requested a
Neapolitan ice cream sandwich the truck
rumbled for a moment before dispensing
what seemed to be a ham and cheese
sandwich with slices of tomato however
upon taking a bite out of the sandwich
the researcher found that this was
actually just a perfect replica of a ham
and cheese sandwich made from Neapolitan
ice cream the receipt released from the
slot simply said April fools before the
truck drove away without even asking for
any payment the same researcher would
return to the ice cream truck one more
time this time requesting a single scoop
of vanilla ice cream in a waffle cone it
was provided to him without issue and he
happily paid the 72 cents the truck
requested in return the next test
wouldn't go quite as swimmingly by which
which we mean it caused a horrifying
death this time a slightly more senior
researcher wanted to perform a test on
the ice cream truck he asked for a peach
flavored push pop which he received
without issue however when he refused to
pay the price an admittedly steep
$16 all hell broke loose as he tried to
walk away the hatch opened a full 6 ft
releasing its large rusty metal trap
around the senior researcher he was
pulled into the truck followed by a
horrific rumbling noise not long after
the slot began to spew a stream of pink
liquid for a Solid 5 minutes before
driving away this pink puree was later
proven to be a genetic match to the
researcher after this the foundation
refused to allow any other researchers
to interact with SCP 1386 only d-class
Personnel would be permitted to take
part in the tests in contrast to the
senior researchers horrifying death the
d-class Personnel seemed to get along
extremely well with SCP P 1386 the first
d-class asked for a cherry popsicle with
nuts the truck produced an unwrapped
Cherry popsicle with nuts embedded in
the ice along with a receipt reading
$2.20 your nuts the d-class chuckled as
he read the receipt and paid the truck
without incident the second d-class
requested a more esoteric treat a Caesar
salad flavor popsicle however the ice
cream truck isn't one to back down from
a challenge It produced an off- green
popsicle that tasted like quote lightly
dressed lettuce with a hint of croutons
the next d-class ordered a dark
chocolate fudge pop but wasn't able to
pay an exact change he gave the truck $2
bills and was given a carefully wrapped
package with a crude drawing of US
currency on the front when the package
was opened he saw that it contained the
exact change he required down to the
penny he made an official request to the
foundation to keep the change but his
request was denied the foundation then
pushed its d-class person Personnel to
ask for more complex constructions just
to see what a SCP 1386 was capable of
the next d-class asked for a Kinder
Surprise egg the kind which are banned
in the US due to their history as being
a choking hazard however the ice cream
truck didn't have a hard time
constructing the egg except this one was
made out of ice cream rather than
chocolate it did seem beyond the truck's
capability to create the toy inside
instead including a small piece of paper
reading I ow you one toy
the next interaction wasn't quite as
cordial the d-class requested one Cherry
ice Lolly one Cherry ice pop one Cherry
popsicle and one cherry flavored drink
frozen this resulted in the ice cream
truck making a horrifying noise
described as being like someone skinning
a cat in Reverse it then unceremoniously
ejected the Red Ice causing it to
shatter on the ground before releasing a
styrofoam cup filled with frozen green
liquid this liquid was shown to contain
huge quantities of AR
but was thankfully impossible to drink
on account of the fact that its melting
point is so high that it's impossible to
liquefy with current technology and our
current knowledge of SCP 1386 testing
ends with its strangest story of all a
non-verbal declass was instructed to
write his order on a piece of paper to
pass to the truck in hopes of seeing if
it would respond to written commands a
slot opened up in the door a few inches
lower than the usual slot and a thin
flesh colored appendage slithered out
its hand a kind of two-fingered pincher
it took the note from the d-class and
gave him an ice cream cone in return the
declass was visibly disturbed by the
hand saying that it looked horrifying
and smelled like death he even refused
to eat the ice cream saying that he'
lost his appetite but other DCL classes
capable of verbal articulation did not
report any strange occurrences with the
hand they said that they found the hand
to look completely normal and as time
went on they began to trust the ice
cream truck with increasing devotion
while their mistrust in the Disturbed
mute declass only grew in the strangest
Twist of all this d-class was later
found dead in the Cell from
strangulation the d-class was alone in
this cell and there were no signs of
forced entry perhaps he should have
enjoyed his ice cream while he still
could you know what they say ice cream
you scream we all scream for ice cream
and no ice cream is more screamworthy
than the one served up by SCP
1386 Dr blast and his group of
researchers stand behind bulletproof
viewing glass they all have very serious
looks on their face that is until the
first test begins on one side of the
test room a Class D subject stands
holding a sheet of paper on the other
side sits a bright red tomato on a
wooden table Dr blast pushes the
intercom button and speaks into the
microphone all right you may begin
d541 nods and looks down at the sheet of
paper in his hand he begins to read is a
hippopotamus a hippopotamus or really
just a cool opotamus nothing happens
d541 stands there awkwardly waiting a
man next to Dr blast in the observation
room Snickers Dr blast jerks his head
toward the researcher and stares him
down this is not a laughing matter blast
says the reprimanded researcher clears
his throat and stands up straight sorry
sir Dr blast leans over and pushes the
microphone button again proceed to the
next joke D 5041 the man on the other
side of the glass nods and pulls a
second sheet of paper out from behind
the first what's an archaeologist
someone whose career is in Ruins says
d541 a moment after he finishes the joke
The Ripe Red Tomato launches itself off
the table and flies toward the face of
d541 the tomato is clocked at moving 104
mph d541 has no time to move before the
Tomato slams into his nose instantly
breaking it the men in the observation
room behind the bulletproof glass do
their best to hold back their laughter
Dr blast grumbles as he jots down notes
on his clipboard it appears that SCP 504
is a certain taste in jokes he says to
the rest of the researchers in the room
this elicits a slight chuckle this might
indicate sapience I hope not clear the
room and bring in the next subject
medical personnel and a team of
custodial staff enter the room the
Physicians tend to d504 one's nose and
carry him out the custodians clean the
remnants of the Tomato off the floor
walls and ceiling they exit leaving the
room completely empty a moment later the
door opens and another ordinary looking
tomato is brought in and placed on the
desk the SCP agent who brought in the
tomato leaves d542 enters the room a
moment later with a sheet of paper in
his hand he stands on the far side of
the room away from the SCP 504 tomato
sitting on the table he nervously brings
the paper close to his face to read
what's on it three tomatoes are walking
down the street d504 2 says with a
little Shake in his voice he had seen
d541 exit the room just before he
entered with blood and and tomato paste
running down his face a papa tomato a
mama tomato and a little baby tomato
baby tomato starts sling behind POA
tomato gets very angry goes over to the
baby tomato and smooshes him and says
ketchup the new SCP 504 tomato
immediately goes flying from the table
straight toward the joke teller this
time the tomato is clocked at 264 mph
when it slams into the face of d504 2
the impact immediately renders him
unconscious after the first few trials
Dr BL decides that it's time to take
things up a notch the foundation has
collected hundreds of SCP 504 tomatoes
so there is no shortage after the room
is cleaned once again a medical team
removes the unconscious class D
Personnel who was knocked out by the
previous SCP 504 experiment and they're
ready to begin again this time there
will be terrible consequences for their
actions d504 3 enters the room the SCP
504 tomato has already been placed on
the table you may begin Dr blast says
into the microphone the class D
Personnel read the joke on the sheet of
paper he's holding so I was going to bed
and my brother told me good night don't
let the bed bugs stick their probiscus
in your skin and suck your blood D 5043
pauses for a beat good luck unhealthy
dermis he ends the joke for 2 seconds
there's no reaction from SCP 504 Dr
blast thinks this terrible joke just
wasn't one that SCP 504 could understand
suddenly there's a loud crack d504 three
falls to the floor tomato covers where
his face once was when Dr blast and the
other researchers go back and slow down
the video they witnessed the SCP 504
tomato traveling so quickly that it
broke the sound barrier the Tomato
impacted the joke tell at an
unfathomable speed instantly killing him
Dr blast decides that he needs to be
more careful when choosing jokes for the
safety of everyone involved perhaps a
crossbreed between SCP 504 and regular
Tomatoes will yield different results
after the unfortunate death of d504 3
the research team Waits a few days
before experimenting with new strains of
SCP 504 three different cross reads are
brought into the room and placed
equidistant from each other on the table
d544 enters the room Dr blast presses
the intercom button and orders him to
begin if you have Dentures don't use
artificial sweetener cuz you'll get a
fake cavity says d544 the moment the
joke ends all three Tomatoes launched
toward him at 145 mph they hit him
Square in the face two teeth are
dislodged and the test subject is
covered in the remains of the three
squashed Tomatoes interesting notes Dr
blast all the tomatoes reacted in the
same way so now we know multiple
instances of SCP 504 will go after the
same joke maker he pauses to think for a
moment what if we cut up the tomatoes
the test room is reset another SCP 504
tomato is brought in and cut up into
quarters D 5045 enters the room and
begins his joke I tried to walk into a
Target but I miss all four pieces of the
Tomato speed toward d504 5's face they
slam into a at 212 mph one of the pieces
of tomatoes impales itself into his eye
instantly ly destroying it the medical
team rushes in and removes the howling
subject from the room Dr blast writes
vigorously on his clipboard we're
starting to go through test subjects too
quickly he announces let's try a
recording and see if SCP 504 will react
to that the research team brings in a
new tomato a CD player and the harmful
if swallowed album by Dane Cook the CD
begins to play during one of the jokes
the Tomato launches itself off the table
and slams into the CD player causing
both the stereo and the Tomato to
shatter into several pieces the Tomato
was clocked at 167 mph it would appear
that SCP 504 reacts to the recordings as
well we didn't even have to deal with
the damn class D's in the first place
says Dr blast he informs his team that
since the risk level is now relatively
low they can continue the experiments
without him he leaves the observation
room to get some rest the other
researchers look at one another
mischievous Smiles crossing their faces
as they begin to laugh the SCP 504
research team sets up three new tomatoes
and brings three class D subjects into
the the room the researchers then
Retreat back into the observation area
and begin a joke over the intercom
system while the class D Personnel wait
patiently in the room with the SCP 504
Tomatoes The Following news item has
just been released said one of the
researchers over the intercom bomb blows
whole in linen statue the first test
subject finishes the joke with the
ending written on his sheet of paper ooh
that's going to leave a marks test
subject one says the first tomato
Twitches but does not leave its location
on the table the second test subject
reads for his paper BBC is just stalling
the good news the second tomato leaves
the table at 152 mph and slams into the
jaw of the second test subject causing a
hairline fracture in a chipped tooth the
third test subject looks at the ending
to the joke on his paper and begins to
shake nervously he speaks two words
which he knows will not end well for him
that blows the third SCP 504 tomato
flies off the table slams into the third
test subject's head and instantly knocks
him out the test subject is sent to the
hospital with a m massive skull fracture
the next day Dr blast bursts into the
observation room and reprimands the
research team I thought we just
established that recordings work in
place of live subjects screams Dr blast
I know how much you guys hate class D's
especially d412 but the poor guy might
not ever recover before his termination
rolls around I'm making it clear right
now that whoever oversaw this round of
testing is getting serious reprimand the
same goes for whoever leaked its video
logs to the staff everyone is silent
from somewhere within the group of
research there's a Snicker then they all
break out in laughter after this
incident no class DS or other Personnel
are used in research being conducted on
SCP 504 the research team Wheels in a
television playing the Sarah Palin and
Hillary Clinton SNL skit the Tomato
shows signs of confusion as it flies off
the table its trajectory includes three
separate bursts of speed over 200 mph
two stretches of motion at normal
throwing speed and one unprecedented
instance of the Tomato moving backwards
this all occurs during the flight of a
single SCP 5 4 tomato during the SNL
skit the working hypothesis is that the
Tomato was unsure whether to take the
video seriously or not the research team
later finds out that scp-504 really
hates Science and Mathematics jokes when
they bring in a laptop that plays a
pre-recorded engineering joke over the
speakers a mechanical voice can be heard
saying 2009 is going to be a complex
year we already know the real part we
still have to find the imaginary part at
the conclusion of the joke there's a
supersonic blast and the computer is
completely vaporized by the Tomato's
kinetic energy the sensors recorded an
approximate speed of
2,174 mph as the tomato flew across the
room the conclusion of the experiments
on SCP 504 end with another computer
being brought into the test room the
computers begin to play the money python
sketch of the funniest joke in the world
toward the end of the skit the Allied
Forces are reciting the funniest joke in
the world in German to defeat the Nazis
the actors chant when is get slauter
yeah be OD flipper vault at the end of
the joke the Tomato explodes on the
table where it once sat debris from the
Tomato coats the entire room including
the computer the researchers conclude
that SCP 504 did not know what to do
with the funniest joke in the world so
it's self-terminated Dr blast sits in
the cafeteria quietly eating his lunch
reading over the logs for the SCP 504
experiments suddenly a commotion breaks
out in the kitchen there are screams of
Terror Dr blast jumps out of his seat
runs to the kitchen door pushes it open
to his surprise he sees slices of
tomatoes flying around the room someone
on the research team thought it'd be
funny to give the unknowing kitchen
staff scp-504 tomatoes to see what would
happen after they had been cut up and
put into food for the day someone in the
kitchen told a bad joke and the tomato
slices flew around like shukin Dr blast
sees a group of researchers peering
through a kitchen window and laughing
hysterically he'll get to the bottom of
which researchers did this and they will
be fired from the SCP Foundation for a
moment we we want you to cast your mind
back to your childhood a time when you
weren't as busy or burdened with the
pressures of life that come as you grow
up when you were carefree and had your
whole life ahead of you nothing but
potential and opportunity a simpler time
when the highest award you could achieve
wasn't a grade or a promotion but
something as simple as your mom or dad
pinning a drawing you did to the door of
the refrigerator oh to be a kid again
right then again maybe returning to
younger days is better left as a fantasy
it's hard to imagine that something so
pure so simple and wholesome as a
drawing on the fridge could ever be
something dark horrific even but then
you learn about SCP 683 and all of a
sudden returning to your childhood
becomes something you hope never happens
SCP 683 is an anomaly with various parts
to it so we'll start with SCP
refrigerator to be more precise it's
actually a 1953 Crosley shelvador for
any of you fridge experts out there who
are curious about the exact make and
model of SCP
the ordinary about this particular
fridge apart from maybe some slight wear
and tear on the Outside Inside though
it's perfectly clean kept in perfect
working condition for keeping food cool
but that's the first weird thing about
SCP
683-1196 all that impressive unless
you're a fridge owner yourself and know
what a nightmare they can be to keep
clean while it's definitely weird it's
not the last of SCP
6831 anomalous properties the next is
the fact that the power cord of this
refrigerator ends with a plug that
doesn't match any known type of wall
outlet seems even stranger after all who
would design a fridge that can't even be
plugged in right in fact the SCP
Foundation had to design their very own
completely one-of-a kind adapter to
connect SCP 6831 to an ordinary gas
powerered home generator once plugged in
though SCP
63-12 sort of it's about time we move on
to SCP 683 second component designated
as SCP
using felt pens and pencils presumably
by a child between the ages of 5 and 7
years old there's evidence of some
moderate water damage to the paper but
once again nothing all that strange to
look at even the subject of this child's
drawing is pretty mundane just some
scribbles of a pleasant mountainous
landscape a house a well a dog a figure
wearing a chef's TK and of course an
anthropomorphic son with a smiley face
now sure that might not sound all that
impressive but we would advise you not
to say anything like that out loud
criticizing the drawing is a comment you
might wish you hadn't made just like
when you fill our comment sections with
dated Among Us memes seriously it's
getting old any person that makes any
kind of negative or disparaging remark
about the SCP 6832 drawing or tries to
remove the paper from the fridge door of
SCP
6831 will suffer a grim horrific fate
the next time they try to eat anything
this person will suffer immense
irreparable damage to their internal
organs along with their skin and muscle
tissue this is intensely painful causing
the subject agonizing pain as their
organs and skin are melted down the
amount the person loses is equal to the
mass of food they've eaten with each
bite they will lose more and more of
their body the painful process will not
stop until they have ingested 42 kg of
food making this even worse the process
doesn't seem to Target any organs that
would kill the subject immediately
they're made to suffer an excruciating
pain punished with torture for daring to
try and remove the drawing from the
fridge any and all subjects will die
within 26 days of taking that final bite
and thus losing the last piece of
themselves but where do the body parts
of these people go surely they don't
disappear you must be thinking and you
would be right in instances like this
the Third mystery component of SCP 683
is revealed referred to as SCP
683-3818 also a plastic Ziploc bag in
which you'll find the other half of the
stolen organs and flesh of this unlucky
person along with three chocolate chip
cookies surprisingly these are actually
completely normal cookies with no traces
of DNA or other abnormalities to them
every time there is also one final item
that forms the contents of SCP
as appears on the outer surface of the
paper bag upon which a single name is
written Eric now for those of you in the
know about the various anomalies of the
SCP Foundation that particular
unassuming name might sound very
familiar it was the same name mentioned
by another anomaly known as SCP
066 a brief bit of context for you SCP
066 was a living ball of yarn that
displayed friendly Behavior towards
Foundation staff however during an
experiment a thread was cut from SCP 0
66's body this caused the yarn to
transform into a ball of meat with a
pair of functional eyes protruding from
it SCP 066 became hostile constantly
asking for an Eric whenever someone gets
too close to it the same name Eric was
also found carved into the back of SCP
168 another anomaly encountered by the
SCP Foundation scp1 168 was an anomalous
calculator which actually possessed some
level of of sentients and had the
ability to communicate so who is Eric
well theories range far and wide but
there's no real definitive answer as to
exactly who or what Eric might be some
claim he's a reality bending entity
others posit he's an SCP that the
foundation just doesn't know about yet
regardless he's connected to some
intriguing entities a sentian calculator
a formerly friendly ball of yarn and a
fridge with a child's drawing on it that
can steal people's organs and put them
in a lunch bag especially for him it
would seem that Eric is a child maybe a
school boy possibly even the one
responsible for the drawing on SCP 683
this child could even potentially be
anomalous in nature of course this is
all just rampant speculation on our part
so it's probably best to take all of
that with a grain of salt as we've said
before it is just a theory an SCP
explained Theory Eric might just remain
one of the foundation's many unanswered
mysteries for years to come but if that
answer doesn't satisfy you then why
don't we go back to SCP 683 maybe
something in the frid's origin will give
us a further clue to the mystery of who
Eric is the fridge was first discovered
by the SCP Foundation in the storage
unit of a Washington Home owned by a
woman named Yolanda as coincidence would
have it Yolanda was a collector of
vintage home furnishing including
refrigerators which would probably
explain why she didn't think to throw
out such an old model of fridge from the
1950s according to her she found SCP 683
simply left on a nearby street corner
with nobody around that could have left
it there or anyone that could have
possibly been transporting it to the
local dump to give her a hand moving the
fridge Yolanda Enlisted the help of her
nephew who agreed to step in and assist
her in getting SCP 683 back to her house
unfortunately fortunately though the
nephew passed away only 2 weeks later
apparently due to Medical complications
that came as the result of a hernia
according to his death certificate could
Yolanda's nephew have been the
mysterious and Elusive Eric could
something have happened to him after his
death that allowed him to become some
kind of anomaly who's to say we can only
guess and hope that one day we might get
a full answer as to why Yolanda never
suffered the effects of SCP 683 she
never actually tried to take the SCP
6832 drawing down from the fridge when
asked why she simply replied it's a nice
little picture isn't it why take it down
maybe just maybe it might have even
reminded her of her nephew it would have
been a futile and foolish idea for
Yolanda to have even tried to remove the
drawing at any rate as any who try will
suffer that painful and horrifying
process of losing their organs and
having them appear in Eric's paper lunch
bag even fire came can't remove the
drawing from the fridge at least not
permanently suggesting that even the
paper it is drawn on has its own
anomalous properties on three separate
occasions the SCP Foundation has
attempted to test this setting SCP 6832
on fire with nothing more than a match
every time the drawing was incinerated
burning to ashes until there was nothing
left but within 68 hours SCP 6832 had
returned to its permanent fixture on the
fridge door as if nothing had happened
interestingly though the d-class members
of personnel that were instructed to
burn the drawing didn't suffer the usual
anomalous effects of SCP 683 a similar
thing happens if multiple people attempt
to remove SCP 6832 or say anything
negative towards the drawing in cases
like this only the very first person who
made a disparaging remark or trying to
rip the drawing from the fridge will be
the one to suffer a long painful torture
by organ removal followed swiftly by
death now if you cast your mind back to
earlier in the video we told you that
someone who tries removing or disparages
SCP
means you're heading towards an even
slower painful death from starvation to
date two different Foundation test
subjects have died this way by refusing
to eat after interacting with SCP 683
true the SCP Foundation is most likely
sitting on a whole calvacade of
different anomalies that can keep a
person alive without the need for food
but you know what they're like right the
foundation's hardly likely to share the
keys to surviving without having to eat
and there you have it folks that's SCP
683 don't worry it's highly unlikely
that you'll ever encounter it the
foundation keeps it under lock and key
in a Cell fitted with a steel door and
reinforced hinges SCP 683 remains
covered in a large cloth to prevent any
members of personnel from looking at it
when the fridge isn't being used for
research or experiments but you have to
wonder what if it's not the only fridge
with these anomalous properties after
all it's rare for a manufacturer to make
just a single refrigerator of a certain
model maybe you'd better be wearing next
time you visit someone with an older
model of fridge in their kitchen and
just to be safe if there is a drawing
pin to the front door leave it where it
is feeling hungry maybe you could go for
a snack right about now or a nice
refreshing can of your favorite soda
perhaps if you've got some change
burning a hole in your pocket a nearby
vending machine would be a good choice
and Trust TR us there's no vending
machine like this one SCP 261 will give
you a treat that's out of this world or
rather out of this Dimension that's how
this safe class anomaly earned its
incredibly accurate name the
interdimensional vending machine it was
first discovered in a dark alley in
Yokohama Japan Japan is a place where
you can find a number of strange and
surprising things in vending machines
but nothing quite like this the
foundation was for first alerted to its
presence after one of their web trollers
noticed some interesting chatter on
Japanese online message boards about a
magic vending machine to these Japanese
Forum users it sounded like a fanciful
urban legend a vending machine where you
could get something truly Fantastical if
you have the yen to spare but upon
thorough investigation field agents of
the SCP Foundation discovered that the
machine was no Legend and brought it
into containment it's the kind of thing
you wouldn't look twice at and utterly
generic black vending machine with no
viewing window and a handwritten sign in
Japanese that reads out of order but
what the vending machine looks like
isn't nearly as interesting as what it's
capable of when you insert your money
into the machine and it's important to
note that it only accepts Japanese Yen
the machine will dispense some kind of
snack food or drink item however over
time the more the machine is used in a
single day the more bizarre the items it
spits out will become Foundation
researchers have attempted to figure out
how the machine works but their task has
been incredibly difficult so far it
doesn't appear to contain any snacks and
it doesn't seem to be made of any
anomalous Parts moreover the machine
simply won't work when the front panel
is open or when any surveillance
equipment is placed inside in other
words it's pretty much impossible to
look this gift horse in the mouth
strangely the machine is also capable of
working without power though when
unpowered the vended products are likely
to become stranger much faster but let's
be honest here you're not here for
vending machine mechanics 101 you want
to hear about all the weird stuff that
SCP 261 dispenses and frankly we're with
you on that one lucky for all of us this
is one of the anomalies that the
foundation has truly extensive test
records on providing us with a highlight
reel of some of the strangest wildest
and downright most interesting snacks
and drinks straight out of another
dimension bone Appetit let's start off
nice and easy with some of the snacks
and drinks that are not only edible but
also sound like they'd actually be
pretty tasty like Pepsi Dragon twist a
bottle of Pepsi soda with English
packaging that tastes like dragon fruit
Pepsi Co does not produce such a product
but honestly we wish they did same for
Dark Side Cola a clear liquid that
becomes jet black shortly after being
opened which apparently tastes like your
average can of coke with A Touch of
Spice thrown in but hey not not
everybody likes Cola maybe you're a
Maverick a rebel only a soft drink with
a formal title can quench your thirst
and as such you prefer Dr Pepper in
which case maybe the vending machine
will furnish you with an
interdimensional Japanese product known
as Dr Pepper's amusing straw this
spatial anomaly wrapped inside a
Whimsical Dr Pepper branded straw seems
to contain far more liquid than should
be able to fit in the straw about one
bottle worth of soda to be precise a
nice and convenient solution for
whenever you need to get the fix that
only an accredited doctor of popology
can provide and if you fancy something
from the more intoxicating end of the
beverage Spectrum for 600 Yen you can
get yourself a rare bottle of Billy beer
it's just the thing for those who
weren't alive during the Carter
Administration but still want to try
brew that was endorsed by the younger
brother of President Jimmy Carter this
anomalous bottle of Suds which was
bottled in the 1970s according to its
label came with a note reading I have
had this beer brewed just for me I think
it's the best I've ever tasted and I've
tasted a lot I think you'd like it too
Billy Carter drinking the beer got a
declass intoxicated for 72 hours but
what if you've just wet your whistle and
worked up a hunger in the process
thankfully SCP 261 has some delicious
interdimensional food to satisfy your
Cravings so for starters how about a
tube of the little Bakery s grain this
small aluminum tube lets you squeeze out
a blob of dough which instantly Rises
and Cooks itself into a tasty little
loaf of bread testing is indicated that
the bread is a little chewy but still
tastes completely fine not bad for a
tubed baked good how about some seafood
to go with that bread then maybe for
your entree you can crack open a
delicious pack of lemon clams and we do
mean crack very literally here if you
crack this bag of anomalous clams like a
glow stick they boil themselves and once
you open them you're ready to enjoy a
serving of tasty clams that have a
slight lemon flavoring to them delicious
but if you're not that hungry and just
feeling more like a snack than a full
fancy dinner the machine once put out
the lay blooming onion while it appears
to be a normal onion each layer of the
onion is a different flavor of Chip
leading all the way into the middle
truly a gourmet snack with more layers
than well actually exactly as many
layers as an onion and what about for
those who are anomalously trapped in the
year 2012 and are looking for a snack
that is both tasty and mem worthy well
you'd be lucky to receive a 700 Yen
bacon shirt it's exactly what it says on
the can an edible shirt that both smells
and tastes like bacon and has no real
side effects other than making you smell
a little like bacon while you're wearing
it though this could be a dangerous
anomalous effect if you decide to walk
through your local dog park while you're
wearing it we've been told it pairs well
with the meat hat Teriyaki Fedora a size
64 tril Style Al fadora made entirely
out of Teriyaki flavored beef jerky the
object came flattened in a cardboard box
bearing the tagline you can have your
hat and eat it too which is a pun that
probably makes a lot more sense in their
Dimension still a bit hungry well lucky
for you this magical vending machine has
got you covered on dessert too for 700
Yen the foundation was given an entire
edible chest set with each of the ornate
pieces carve from what seemed like hard
Pez Style candy it's less checkm made
and more check 8 another pun that I
promise is funnier in another dimension
and for 300 Yen extra you might walk
away with a candy robot playset these
are more hard candy components that can
be put together to create functional
anomalous mini robots that move on their
own walking aimlessly and bumping into
walls but what about the full meal
craving consumer on the go who wants
both a dinner and a dessert combined
into one disgusting package don't worry
the interdimensional vending machine has
got you covered just 400 Yen can net you
some delicious turdo chaken these are
balls of fried turkey filled with
chocolate a smaller ball of duck more
chocolate and in the very center a small
ball of fried chicken even the labeling
on the product describes it as having
450% of an adult human's daily
recommended fat intake we'll leave it to
you to decide if this is a decadent
treat worthy of the gods or utterly
disgusting maybe you're feeling a little
cheeky though or you need the perfect
comedic dessert for your bachelorette
party the vending machine has a candy
direct from an alternate Korea a tasty
if slightly too sweet chocolate candy
shaped like a certain male organ filled
with we kid you not liquid white
chocolate perfect for anyone who has
both the sweet tooth and the sense of
humor of a 12-year-old okay these were
definitely all weird Treats but let's
get really really strange now from the
disgusting to the confusing to the
inedible to the straight up deadly if
you're a bit of a stist perhaps you're
the kind of person who enjoys watching
their snacks dying in front of them
before they eat them for that the
vending machine provides an aluminum box
with a viewing window and a red button
on top inside are a collection of small
furry creatures each with a single big
eye when the button is pressed the
creatures inside are abruptly
superheated cooking them all to death at
that point the Box opens and the
creatures are ready to eat we've been
told they were crunchy spicy and tasted
a little like beef maybe you're part of
the slow food movement for that we
recommend the delicious pile of slugs
which is exactly what it sounds like
this is a produce box like the kind used
for packing strawberries except it's
full of live slugs there are both
advantages and disadvantages to actually
eating these slugs the advantage is that
they contain large amount amounts of
vitamin C E and most of the B complex
which are all crucial to a healthy and
balanced diet the disadvantage is that
they contain large amounts of arsenic
which will kill you though of course if
you still have a candy flavored death
wish but you prefer your entomological
treats a little more leggy then may we
interest you in a fine caramelized
spider for a modest 500 yen it's full of
deadly quantities of an unknown
anomalous Venom that's pretty much
impossible to cure but it's wor worth it
for the Sweet Sticky goodness that comes
before death sets in another strange
item dispensed by the vending machine
was a tall metal aluminum canister with
a ring pole that upon opening had a
violent chemical reaction with the air
and triggered a large explosion
apparently this particular beverage was
never intended for oxygenated
environments the blast killed two
researchers and resulted in the
temporary suspension of testing though
in a slight silver lining for this
Fiasco the testing area did smell of
citrus for a few days which the janitors
must have enjoyed as they cleaned up all
the body parts another dangerous snack
provided by the vending machine was a
long tube of chips called prangles not
to be confused with any other long two
Bas chips you may be thinking of when
the tube was opened or popped as they
say the d-class that the chips were
presented to began compulsively eating
them when researchers ordered the
d-class to stop it seemed almost as if
they couldn't regard of the orders given
to them the d-class just kept eating
even when guards terminated the d-class
there and then the corpse continued to
eat chips out of the tube until it was
physically pried out of their hands but
if all those salty prangles had really
worked up a thirst in you perhaps you
can wash them down with a delicious can
of cherry balm an intense cherry
flavored drink dispensed by SCP 261 for
450 Yen when a declass sampled this
delicious soda they commented on it tast
tasting strongly of cherry a few moments
later their head exploded with the force
of a stick of dynamite coating everyone
and everything around it in gooey head
visera the resulting cleanup took an
arduous 6 hours but wow was that cherry
tasty and finally why not complete this
anomalous vending machine Feast with a
1,000 yen papier-mâché pinata resembling
a dead horse that comes ready to use
with a baseball bat everyone who saw the
Piata fell compelled to Beat It
mercilessly with the bat until candy
began to fall out many in attendance
claimed that it was the 1,000th gift
Unleashed by SCP 261 and thus warranted
celebration once the dead horse was
thoroughly beaten all Cognito hazardous
properties ceased there's a joke
somewhere in there but for the life of
us we're not sure we can find it oh well
maybe it's in another dimension working
at the SCP Foundation can really get
your appetite going after spending a
rough shift monitoring the acid levels
in SCP 682s tank or performing the
rituals necessary to keep the devour of
worlds on the other side of SCP
2317 sometimes you just need a quick
snack to hold you over before you return
to the old grind problem is at the SCP
Foundation even the break room can be
perilous Dr Dan is notorious for
pilfering pudding cups from the communal
fridge and ever since the administrator
himself stole your tuna sandwich you
just don't feel safe spending your lunch
break on sight anymore
but this presents its own series of
issues you only have an hour for lunch
and obviously you can't order in due to
security issues also if you're eating
off site you have even less time to
finish your lunch because the site
you're currently stationed at is
relatively remote we're talking at least
a half hour round trip to actually get
to somewhere so you're going to need
your food fast and when it comes to fast
food few eateries are as prolific as the
golden arches McDonald's and just to
clarify this video is not sponsored
we're going to tell you about a
horrifying anomalous secret that this
company really doesn't want you to know
about let's not think about that just
yet though your stomach is rumbling and
you need that quarter pounder so bad
that even being trapped in the red
reality with Dr Scranton couldn't stop
you from getting it when you finally
arrive you buy your typical order a
quarter pounder with french fries a
coffee and a McFlurry you see Dr kleff a
few tables down enjoying a box of
chicken nuggets and ketchup but decide
not to engage as you sit and enjoy your
me your little lunch knowing you'll
probably be coordinating the cleaning
efforts of scp1 73's containment chamber
by the end of the day your eyes drift
over to something even more unsettling
happy the current mascot for McDonald's
Happy Meals you can't help but shudder
you've seen some pretty horrific things
on the job nightmarish things you fear
no monster but that thing it's scares
you those big soulless eyes the wide
gaping ma full of two white tee teeth
it's diabolical sneakers no child should
ever have to look at that you can't help
but wonder whatever happened to Ronald
McDonald the hamburger happy clown that
shielded fast food to you throughout
your childhood what is he up to now well
we have an answer for you but I'll warn
you you may not be quite as eager to
suck down a Big Mac and a DI of coke
after hearing this Ronald McDonald first
introduced as the company's mascot in
1963 had a pretty good run before
finally being largely phased out by the
company in the mid-2010s for a greater
focus on the nasty little box homunculus
you can thank John Wayne gasy Pennywise
and those goofballs dressed up as clowns
back in 2016 for that but like anyone
who loses favor State Side Ronald had a
prosperous career ahead of him outside
the country well not the Ronald we know
at least you see in an undisclosed
cattle farm in 2004 most likely in North
America a monster was born a horrific
Abomination birthed from a cow like many
have theorized about SCP 058 the Heart
of Darkness but this nasty little
creature wasn't a giant heart with a
stinger and Scorpion legs in many ways
it appeared superficially humanoid save
for its stark white skin its thick red
lips and its full head of bright frizzy
red hair but that was only the start of
the unnerving strangeness exhibited by
this miracle child it was born with
white gloves and long clownish shoes
seemingly grafted to its feet fresh from
birth the creature was huge with a
disproportionately large head and wide
disgusting pores that seemed to
perpetually leak fry oil the creature
was unresponsive to any kind of external
stimuli perhaps suggesting it was brain
dead and it remained completely dormant
most of the time while most people would
have screamed run away or called the
police the farmers at this particular
cattle farm decided to let it ride and
see how this whole nightmarish Affair
played out that sense of curiosity and
patience would soon pay off for them
financially it didn't take long for the
creature to grow the bigger it got the
more it looked like a giant mutant
version of McDonald's iconic mascot
Ronald McDonald and this wasn't just a
coincidence either it turned out that
this monster was somehow intrinsically
linked to the McDonald's brand because
once a day the creature would
horrifically unhinge its jaw and begin
to barf out a huge quantity of
McDonald's food and we're not talking
about raw materials that are converted
into McDonald's food the creature later
dubbed SCP
5962 vomited out fully packaged
McDonald's products the owners of this
clownish monster had just hit the
lottery so to speak while the
particulars of the deal are unclear they
somehow contacted a representative of
the McDonald's corporation based in
China in exchange for presumably a large
sum of money Chinese McDonald's
operatives covertly entered the country
and shephered the now massive creature
over to McDonald's owned Warehouse in
Beijing by this point it was around 4 M
tall and weighed over 5 tons it was kept
inside a cage and housed at some cost
but soon enough the creature was paying
for itself as we mentioned before the
creature constantly secreted fry oil
which was siphoned off for use in
preparing McDonald's food across the
country the huge quantity of package
food that had vomited out every day was
also shipped off to restaurants across
the country making the Chinese branch of
McDonald's incredibly financially
successful they were able to make an
almost complete profit on all of these
foods and drinks once transport costs
were subtracted of course SCP 5962 had
become McDonald's China's best kept
secret but of course no secret this
Sensational could stay under wraps
forever no matter how much people in the
warehouse were paid or threatened for
their silence if your day job was
siphoning grease off of a giant mutant
clown for the purpose of preparing
McDonald's food across the country
there'd be no way you wouldn't speak to
to somebody about it nobody knows whose
loose lip sunk this incredibly
profitable ship but rumors began to
spread around Beijing about a huge clown
inside of a McDonald's packaging
facility that was when local field
agents of the SCP Foundation finally
took notice two agents Jonathan Jang and
George nagasa were dispatched to perform
an infiltration Mission along with a
team of backup Personnel they entered
the warehouse apprehending any employees
they found as they and their
reinforcements reached the northern side
of the facility
they found SCP 5962 with a heavy collar
around its neck chained to the ground
like King Kong as McDonald's employees
wielded away carts of package food
neither of the attending agents were
fans of McDonald's food but even then
just seeing this horrible display was
enough to make them feel nauseous the
creature was taken and contained by the
SCP Foundation who conducted a number of
tests on it they found that the monster
had no real internal organs save for 27
interconnected stomachs genetically they
also found that the creature was far
more cow than human the same could sadly
not be said for the food that SCP 5962
was vomiting out seriously if you are
already feeling a little queasy from all
this we need to warn you that this is
the part where things get really vile
let's talk about what the McDonald's
food barfed up by SCP 5962 was actually
made out of as we mentioned earlier the
food exuded by the creature was
genetically human with DNA often
matching that of people who are alive
and in no way affected by this anomalous
process tests have indicated that
certain foods condiments and beverages
correspond to more specific types of
bodily tissue and liquid for example the
bacon and Fries were shown to be
cartilage and ligaments the bread turned
out to be made from hair nails and skin
the coffee was liquefied fecal matter
the chicken nuggets were made from
fingers ovaries and testes even the
water was a mix of saline and sweat and
of course the ice cream was comprised of
pus bone marrow feces and nasal mucus
depending on the flavor you get the idea
we'll stop listing off examples before
you lose your lunch but rest assured all
of the food produced by SCP 5962 was
made of human organic matter when the
SCP Foundation interviewed Mr Chen the
manager of the facility where SCP 5962
was being held before his amnestic
treatment he seemed incredibly casual
about the whole thing as far as he was
concerned the food still tasted exactly
the same as regular McDonald's food and
it didn't appear to have any adverse
health effects beyond what you could
expect from regular non-anomalous fast
food it's actually less cruel and
disturbing than the slaughter houses
where the meat is typically obtained Mr
Chen also contested that SCP 5962 wasn't
all that dangerous either the only time
it ever performed an offensive action
was when an employee of the enemy fast
food franchise Burger King entered its
vicinity the creature vomited a stream
of hot coffee at the corporate
interloper like a fire hose until he
left suggesting that it does have some
kind of strange inherent loyalty to the
McDonald's company but still other than
this isolated incident the creature has
never even displayed sentience it was a
big strange clownish McDonald's food
dispenser when questioned about the
origins of SCP
5962 Mr Chen once again underplayed the
strangeness of the situation saying that
he'd heard rumors the farm that sold him
as CP 5962 had also sold other strange
anomalous creatures to eager buyers in
the US ass the farm which we can only
assume is situated right next to a
radioactive waste dump was also behind
SCP
4158 also known as Big Charlie this
giant omnivorous and seemingly Immortal
mutant cow is believed to have been
birthed from a non-anomalous cow sold to
the Butcher Block slaughterhouse it
looked hideous and seemed to suffer from
a wide variety of health issues leading
to the employees at the slaughterhouse
trying to put the creature out of its
misery however no matter how hard they
they tried to kill the monster it just
wouldn't die its bones were pretty much
indestructible and no matter how much of
its flesh was cut off it just kept
growing back causing no ill effects to
the creature itself eventually The
Slaughterhouse workers tried cooking and
eating the meat leading to them
discovering it tasted just as good as
nonanomalous meat much like the Chinese
McDonald's and SCP
5962 the workers had just hit the
lottery with big Charlie as long as they
kept feeding the monster which ate
everything from bricks to other
non-anomalous cows it provided a pretty
much Limitless supply of meat giving
them unprecedented economic prosperity
in other words big Charlie was a literal
Cash Cow Jeff fine the slaughterhouse
director even started worshiping big
Charlie as a kind of demigod by drinking
his blood he believed that big Charlie
was a savior sent to lift them all out
of their struggle and Desperation sadly
for them the SCP Foundation sent them
right back when big Charlie escaped
their slaughterhouse and Foundation
field agents found secured and contained
it it was a sad day for the Butcher
Block so what have we learn today
whether you're in the US OFA or the
Chinese Heartland if you're chowing down
on fast food you really have no idea
where it came from I mean we kind of
knew that already but for all we know
the food you're enjoying could have just
been vomited up by a giant fat clown or
cut from the Flesh of a mutated cow just
think about that next time you're
enjoying a burger but hey let's be
honest with ourselves we'll all probably
still eat it you feel the Panic making
your temperature rise like chili oil on
the tongue as you race down an Alleyway
narrowly avoiding the Carnage unfolding
all around you ducking behind a wall you
press your back against the brick hoping
that if you maybe just stay still you'll
avoid getting caught in the crossfire
War has come to the streets of this
small New York town but it is unlike any
conflict you could have ever imagined
the township of ago hasn't just been
turned into a war zone it's a cow Zone
staring at you on the opposite wall of
the alleyway are posters overlapping
posters all of the exact same
advertisements for the aglo hot slice
they're everywhere covering the whole
wall with scrawled lettering hand drawn
over each one that reads all hail Kevin
aglo hot slice loves you join us eat eat
eat eat eat come be with us come be with
us we love you it's like a nightmare
that you can't wake up from everything
around you serving up a reminder that
you're in deep dish and any moment now
you'll be dead meat taking a deep breath
to steady yourself you grip your camera
in your trembling fingers removing the
lens cap and holding on tight as you
peer out from the alleyway to snap some
shots of the front lines the world needs
to know about this Mayhem all the lives
lost and marinara spilled in a senseless
exchange of violence the lens brings the
moving shapes down the street into Focus
but you still can't believe that they're
real the soldiers of this War aren't
human not all of them at least you
distinctly remember seeing two human
combatants the leaders of these Waring
factions one of the foot soldiers is
clashing with an enemy a homunculus
almost in the vague shape of of a person
facing off against a metallic Mass armed
with circular blades as your finger
presses the shutter you capture the
closing moments of their Fight The
homunculi Swinging a large formless arm
almost like it's made out of a lump of
clay missing hands and fingers of its
own trying to use brute strength against
its metal opponent the next shot shows
the metallic creature slicing through
the homunculus with deadly practiced
efficiency leaving nothing but a pile of
dough and cheese leaking thick goopy
marinara sauce onto the asphalt you
lower your camera tears streaming down
your face as you look around and see
scenes like that unfolding all around
you they're fighting in every building
on every street corner the Thunder of
artillery strikes and explosions from
crashing drones are deafening war is
hell and now you've seen that for
yourself firsthand but while your
attention is fixated on the horrors of
bread and cheese-based warfare erupting
all around you you don't notice a
hulking Pizza creature lumbering behind
you ready to strike Welcome to aglo New
York Ground Zero in a war unlike any
other a conflict that the SCP Foundation
has designated as SCP
4201 like any War it's important to know
who the key players are what the
inciting incidents were that triggered
it and what deep-seated ideological
differences are being fought over it's p
a war between two pizza restaurants oh
really well that sure seems a little
Half Baked oh didn't like that one too
cheesy for
you in that case pop some lactose
tablets and grab a slice of the action
ready to understand exactly how and why
these two rival businesses turned to
enemies duking it out on the battlefield
do you remember the 23rd night of
September because that's when the
municip of aglo New York welcomed a
brand new eery to its humble Township
their local paper The aglo Herald was on
the scene to report on the grand opening
of the aglo hot slice a new Pizzeria
established by local resident Kevin
Kerber now you might not think that the
opening of a new pizza place would be
all that newsworthy but for one not much
happens in aglo New York and for another
what made this a notable occurrence for
the locals was that the opening of the
aglo hot slice put the fledgling
Pizzeria in the crosshairs of a local
staple Mario's Pizza de
deloso history would come to know the
23rd night of September
1997 as the day the first shot was fired
in a war that would consume alow in
Flames like a wood burning oven for over
35 years Mario bian's traditional
Italian Pizzeria had been a local
fixture a homegrown icon bringing the
people of aglo hand tossed dough that
was Woodfired to Perfection and served
with a smile but smiles turned to sour
scows as Kevin Kerber opened up the hot
slice many aglo residents feared that
this challenge to Mario's Pizza de
deloso would drive business away from
the longstanding local favorite but
there was a division of public opinions
with others glad for the arrival of the
aglo hot slice and the potential a new
Pizzeria had to break the Monopoly
Mario's had on the localized market for
his own part the founder of the aglo hot
slice Kevin Kerber had no intentions of
musling in on Mr bian's Turf Kevin lived
in aglo for his entire life and had
plenty of fond memories of visiting
Marios to enjoy a slice with his friends
back when he was still in middle school
he was nothing but amicable towards the
local pizzeria owner and viewed the
opening of his hot slice as nothing more
more than encouraging some healthy
purely professional competition between
the two of them it was Kevin's hope that
the competition would encourage both his
and Mario's businesses to maintain a
consistent quality of their food and in
a sense he was right the quality of both
their pizzas would certainly be put to
the test not just on the battlefield of
ago's Pizza Market but on the actual
Battlefield the town would soon become
to begin with there seemed to be little
animosity between Mario and Kevin's
competing pizzerias for both Mario's
Pizza DEA deloso and aglo hot slice
business was booming while Mario had the
skills in many more years of experience
he was clearly not threatened by the
existence of his new rival yet over his
more than three decades in ago Mario had
consistently put his other competitors
out of business thanks to the quality of
this pizza he even toppled the local
Pizza Hut Outlet so it was clear that he
didn't think there was much cause for
concern when the aglo hot slice opened
its doors Mr biion wasn't one to cower
from his Challenger either he made a
point of trying Kevin Kerber's Pizza
even complimenting it as the best pizza
Mario had ever tasted from a competitor
at least according to Mario in an
interview he gave with the aglo heral
hot slice had nothing on his own pizza
and even claimed that Kevin would have
to step up his game if he wanted a piece
of thecal local pizza pie well not
exactly an explosive retaliation by
Mario biani the oven glove had certainly
been thrown down and the war to
determine who had the strongest pizza
was on their War wasn't initially one
fought with guns and bombs but their
Primary Weapons in their earliest
battles were pizza and advertising
despite the widespread Acclaim his pizza
was earning Kevin simply could not
contend with the longevity and positive
reputation that Mario's Pizza Del deloso
held in aglo he couldn't help that
whenever residents thought of pizza they
automatically thought of maros after all
the garlic season veteran had put five
other competitors out of business
snuffing them out for good and leaving
him as the only Pizzeria standing in ago
but Kevin was determined and nowhere was
that more apparent in his aggressive
marketing campaign for hot slice the
entire town seemed to be covered in
advertisements for Kevin's Pizza
touting the quality customers could
expect from eating there this seemed to
be doing the trick as within its first
week ago's hot slice saw around 7,000
customers impressive figures when you
consider that the town's population was
only around 10,000 it was almost as if
the entire town was mesmerized by Kevin
and his pizza one advertisement featured
in the ow Herald even included the quote
it isn't possible for pizza to be
perfect attributed to someone who's
never tried aglo hot slice within the
first month of hot slice's opening
things started to take a turn for the
strange although the town of AGA wasn't
exactly known for being a hot bed of
extreme weather the night of October 3rd
1997 would have been seen as unusual
anywhere else a freak thunderstorm
rolled into aglo bringing with it a
massive downpour of rain the force of
the storm was actually so great that
many locals found that holes formed in
their roofs letting the water come
pouring in but that wasn't even close to
the strangest part about the storm local
meteorologists estimated that there were
over 700 individual strikes of lightning
that night with the two most notable
locations that were affected being
Mario's Pizza DEA deloso and the ago hot
slice the ladder in particular took a
heavy beating during the storm being
struck by approxim imely 50 lightning
bolts however it seemed that Kevin had
been preparing for the weather despite
how unusual it was for the area almost
as if he had been expecting it he'd
installed 20 lightning rods on his
property meaning the damage was kept to
a minimum as were the effects of the
storm on Marios which remained
relatively unscathed although it
certainly seemed as if the heavens
themselves had chosen a side in the
ongoing feud between the Rival people
piz areas the strange happenings didn't
stop with the freak storm either later
that same month a pair of local
teenagers witnessed something that
baffled them both strange humanoid
creatures in Mario's Pizza deail yoso
the aglo police wrote their story off as
nothing more than teenage hooligan re
likely fueled by elicit substant use but
the two boys Jeffrey aisel and Justin
copper stood by their story regardless
of how inexplicable it sound Ed while
walking around town late one night the
two of them noticed strange movements
inside the pizzeria what first caught
their attention was the lights were
still on well past 11:00 at night
whereas Pizza deail Oso closes at 9:
checking closer the pair of teenagers
tried the front door only to find much
to their surprise that it was still
unlocked stepping inside Jeffrey and
Justin saw Mario biani sitting at one of
the booths in his own restaurant with
pizza slices on the table before him he
began lighting candles and placing them
around the table while reciting a
strange chant that the boys found
incomprehensible but they continued to
watch as he ground up a red chalk-like
substance in his hands then blew the
resultant dust over the pizza slices
given what happened next it's safe to
assume he wasn't trying out a new type
of topping before the terrified and
Confused eyes of the two teens the pizza
formed an inhuman creature it sat up and
scanned the room quickly spotting the
pair of intruders which caused a mouth
to form in its head slice the pizza
homunculus screeched at Jeffrey and
Justin causing Mario to get up and start
yelling at them both to leave 2 Days
Later the strange reports surrounding
the Waring Pizzeria continued to
circulate with even more ads for the hot
slice plastered all over town over the
course of what appeared to be a single
night every square foot of space in aglo
was plastered with new advertisements
there there was no way that Kevin Kerber
acting alone could have placed that many
posters and flyers for his Pizzeria in a
single night to make things even
stranger over 70% of the local residents
had visited the hot slice since the
advertisements were posted with many of
them not coming back out staff from the
AG Herald attempted to investigate but
similarly didn't return making it
impossible for anyone to learn what was
truly going on inside then sometime
after this it happened tensions Rose
getting hotter like melting cheese until
war broke out SCP 4201 is the
designation given to the ensuing
conflict between Mario's Pizza DEA
deloso and the ago hot slice both
restaurants possess their own military
forces each deploying differ weapons and
tactics that seem to be linked to each
different pizzeria's Aesthetics and
theme Mario's troops consisted of large
and H lessly animated homunculi
creatures each one was made out of
various Pizza ingredients including
dough cheese and various other toppings
made to order well to follow orders
these forces were divided into infantry
and Cavalry with their combat style
highly similar to that of the Napoleonic
War era Mario's foot soldiers were all
armed with bayonetted rifles while they
were supported by Cavalry units and
artillery their Commander himself rode
into battle on a construct that
resembled a horse however made out of
the same ingredients as the rest of his
forces while leading his military
efforts Mario uses Pizza based abilities
to support his troops apparently gained
through the same unknown anomalous means
that he used to create his army
meanwhile the opposing forces that serve
under Kevin are mainly drones and robots
constructed around utensils and
appliances typically found in a pizzeria
like ovens or pizza Cutters also acting
as the general of his side Kevin fights
in a large suit of mechanical armor with
several Pizza themed weapons attached to
it he also utilizes more advanced Battle
Tactics and techniques including
deploying his drones with more modern
Firearms as the two Waring factions
Battle For Stuff crust Supremacy over
ago the SCP Foundation has established a
safe Zone around the area evacuating any
and all civilians from the area once
they learned of the doughy disaster
studying the ongoing battle they have
intercepted radio communic Cas between
Mario and Kevin that shed light on their
reasons for continuing their Conflict
for over 20 years in one recording Kevin
lamented the fact that they'd been
fighting so long and that there was no
point in continuing yet Mario refused to
surrender his rival argued that he
couldn't let the newcomer win and take
all of his customers despite Kevin
pointing out that their customers were
dead killed in the crossfire of the
pizza War the pair descended into an
argument with Mario calling Kevin out
for hypnotizing ing the town's folk into
eating at the hot slice and then forcing
them to make his metallic Army while
Kevin rebutted citing how Mario murdered
his earlier competitors through the use
of black magic even with everyone in a
10m radius dead Mario was still obsessed
with defending his Pizzeria he accused
Kevin of never having set foot in Pizza
DEA deloso and that he was nothing more
than a corporate shell with no care or
pride in making Cuisine for people to
this day the pizza war is still ongoing
and has been raging for much longer than
the advertised 30 minutes or less ask
anyone that has been through it and
they'll all tell you the same that
moving home is maybe one of the most
stressful things that a normal person
can ever experience it's a logistical
nightmare right from the start the
moment you talk to a realtor about being
interested in selling your current house
and buying another everything goes
downhill from there after that moment an
avalanche of things comes hurling
towards you finding a place you like
making an offer letting people look
around your house waiting for them to
make a counter offer exchanging
contracts and that's before you even
have thought about packing and as Milo
had learned doing all of that on your
own only makes the stress of moving feel
all the more potent but he had finally
made it after a constant back and forth
with his realer the time had come for
him to pack up all of his worldly
possessions and relocate to a brand new
place to call home he had felt it was
long overdue for him to get a change of
scenery and luckily just the right place
had come onto the market to answer that
call it was a pretty big house bigger
than Milo's previous home but
considerably cheaper in fact he thought
it had been significantly undervalued
the house had an almost Victorian air of
feel to it all beautifully carved and
varnished Woodwork and creaky old
floorboards but in more of an elegant
refined sort of way rather than a a
creepier one that's not to say Milo's
new place wasn't without its more
unsettling elements aside from being big
spacious and easy to imagine as being
haunted the creepiest thing about the
house aside from its frighteningly low
price was the story of what happened to
the previous owners obviously you know
that legally we have to disclose whether
or not anyone died on this property the
realtor had explained wearing a force
grin as she showed Milo around the house
hearing that sentence he could feel the
hairs on the back of his neck stand up
someone died here he asked in disbelief
no no no no of course not sir the
realator instantly walked back her
statement Less in an effort to ease her
client's nerves but more to ensure that
she still closed the deal and earned her
commission bonus then why the hell would
you start a sentence like that Milo
asked we just have to give full
disclosure but I assure you the previous
residents didn't die on the grounds of
this house she gave that fake smile
again it was pretty ineffectual at
reassuring him so what happened to the
last owner well it's a bit of a mystery
to be honest a local Legend if you like
but hey that gives the place more flavor
hearing some spooky history right think
of what a conversation starter that will
be the realator ended her sentence with
a forced snorting laugh but rained it
back in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here the Shaws they were apparently very
quiet reclusive kept to themselves a lot
I'm sure you know the type Milo couldn't
help but notice she shot him a look as
she said that part as if she was
silently passing judgment on the fact he
was planning on moving in alone but they
used to spend a lot of time tending the
garden out front so their neighbors
would see them pretty frequently which
meant they were all okay and no one had
any bad mishaps in the house you know
how old folks can be such a worry when
they get to that age yeah totally Milo
interjected aware the realator was
stalling he repeated so what actually
happened to them well that's the thing
she Shrugged Nobody Knows the full story
one day the neighbors across the street
noticed they hadn't seen Mr and Mrs Shaw
for quite a while so naturally they came
on over here to see if they were in and
the last thing they wanted was to assume
everything was hunky dory here I mean
hey better save them sorry right but
once they got inside they couldn't find
either of them Mr and Mrs Shaw were just
gone vanished Without a Trace most
people on the street thought they had
just sold the place kept it quiet and
moved away retired to somewhere nice and
exotic Oh well that sounds nice I
suppose Milo replied relieved to hear
that there hadn't been any brutal
unsolved murders in the house and that
it most likely wasn't haunted that's
just what the neighbors think anyway the
real letteror continued of course they
hadn't sold the house they just left it
when my firm came in to repossess the
place it had all their belongings in it
some might even still be laying around
here anyway did you want to have a look
at that contract well strictly speaking
Milo was the only human living in his
new house he was never fully alone he
had arrived with his two closest friends
a pair of pets he had adopted while
living in his old house one was a
hamster by the name of donut named after
his round little body and the golden
brown shade of his fur had reminded Milo
of the glaze sugary baked treat the
other was Pixel a bearded dragon with a
pattern on his scales that resembled
some kind of Mosaic Arc the first order
of business Milo had decided was before
even unpacking he needed to make sure
his scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
something else living in the house with
them something that was Far bigger and
was getting much hungrier than either of
his pets would looking around the house
Milo stumbled across a few boxes that he
hadn't brought with him like the
realator had said the shaw still had
some of their possessions left lying
around the place most of it was useless
to Milo old man's clothes or a set of
knitting needles and rolls of colorful
thread it was those particular clues
that seemed to imply Mrs Shaw had a lot
of free time on her hands and maybe took
up knitting as a hobby during retirement
of course the bigger clue was the huge
handmade blanket that Milo found draped
over some of the remaining boxes in the
Attic he wasn't exactly well versed in
knitwear but he could appreciate the
craft behind this soft blanket it
clearly had a lot of time and effort put
into making it painstakingly knitting
each and every individual thread looping
it around a pair of Steel needles and
eventually after hours of wearing out
shaking bony fingers produce something
that actually looked quite nice even
though the idea of sitting and knitting
a blanket might have been one of the
most boring uses of time Milo could
imagine he still had to admit he was
surprised that the Shaws had left this
particular piece of bedding behind it
seemed like it would be pretty comfy to
sleep under it might help keep a person
warm at night now that the colder
seasons were approaching what's more was
that the blanket was clean almost like
it had been freshly washed there was no
old person smell on it no dirt or
discoloration not a stain and it hadn't
even accumulated any dust in its fibers
in fact he noticed that there was hardly
any dust at all up in the attic despite
the house being empty for so long he
assumed the realators had hired someone
As a caretaker while they found a buyer
for the place
and they had kept the place clean after
all what other conclusion could they
have possibly drawn it's not as if
something had eaten all the dust that
would be absurd he'd have a sort through
of the Shaw's leftovers later maybe sell
some of it off at a local yard sale or
give it to a thrift store but that
blanket might come in handy when it
started snowing so Milo had half a mind
to keep it now part of what makes moving
home such a stressful life experience
isn't just all the logistical and
administrative parts of the process it's
only made worse by the fact that it
takes forever to move into a new house
fully that's the part everyone always
forgets about the months after a move
when you're forced to live amongst
towers of cardboard boxes all your
worldly possessions bury deep within
them and you can never remember which
crate anything is in when you urgently
need it so realizing it would take him
much longer to unpack all of his things
Milo set about making sure he had
everything that donut and pixel would
need already to hand the latter of his
two Pets the bearded dragon usually
spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either of his two best buds so
confined but pixel never went very far
anyway content to lay under a heat lamp
almost perfectly still for most of the
day donut on the other hand was much
more of a free spirit the tiny brown
hamster physically could not stay still
and most a seemed to be filled with more
energy than Milo was as a result he let
the little little guy roll about inside
a little plastic ball all day long until
his little hamster feet gave out and now
donut had much more space to zip around
inside his ball so while he entertained
himself Milo could focus on what needed
fixing cleaning and generally improving
around the house it didn't take him long
to realize however that the Realtors had
pulled a bit of a fast one on him
despite the absolute steal of a price
that Milo had been offered it quickly
became clear that the unknown fate of
the previous residence wasn't the only
detail about the house that had been
conveniently kept hidden the place was
in dire need of repair with a lot of the
old woodwork rapidly rotting away if
left unchecked parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seams to
make matters worse the boiler was an
ancient iron monstrosity that was barely
able to produce warm water which would
quickly become an even bigger problem
when the weather started to get colder
then to top off the trifecta of
unforeseen issues and teething problems
with his new place Milo couldn't sleep
it was to be expected after all the
house was old worn out and had
definitely seen better days there were
bound to be a few noises the odd Creek
coming from upstairs when Milo and his
two pets were all downstairs the tapping
of branches against Windows blowing in
the wind outside but for some reason
every audible disturbance that emanated
from some hidden corner of the building
only seemed to get a thousand times
louder when the sun went down at
nighttime every squeaky floorboard or
random noise of the house settling was
nearly deafening enough to pull Milo
right out of what little Restless sleep
he was getting the worst part about it
was though he couldn't help it it made
him feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs Shaw
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the Shaws showing the pair of
them staring disapprovingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creaking
wooden structure of the house and the
sounds it made at night Milo was seeing
the old couple in every bad dream he had
both their faces were locked in those
same still frozen expressions of
contempt as they tried to exercise him
like an interloper on their property
that was the final nail in the coffin
that made Milo realize he needed to look
at other options surely there had to be
some way to induce a deep enough sleep
so that the sounds the house was making
weren't keeping him up or incepting
nightmares anymore he called the local
doctor arranging a consultation for
later that day as he hung up the phone
something nudged against his foot it was
donut having rolled through the Maze of
cardboard boxes still filling the house
house Milo took one look at the little
brown furred hamster then the crates
that still littered the place grabbing
the leftover items that the shs had
forgotten to take with them before they
vanished Milo moved those boxes out into
the shed he knew he was probably
reaching that it was hard likely to make
even the slightest difference to his
sleeping but maybe keeping their stuff
away from him would keep the old couple
out of his head the only thing he kept
in the house was the blanket there was
no use letting it go to waste especially
knowing that the spiler was on the blink
and it would be cold soon he rolled it
up and left it on his bed leaving his
more mobile pet in the same room before
heading out to see the doctor when Milo
got back a bottle of prescription
sleeping pills in his pocket he couldn't
help but notice his room seemed
different the blanket looked like it had
fallen off the bed and onto the floor
for one but more worryingly Donut's
plastic travel ball had been split open
laying in pieces on the ground with its
furly little occupant nowhere to be seen
scene over the next few hours Milo
searched every corner of the house
calling out to his hamster trying to
lure it back with more morsels of food
but donut didn't seem to be anywhere he
wasn't even underneath the knitted
blanket still there was no sign as wor
set in Milo hurly checked pixel's cage
to see if he was gone too but the lizard
was relaxing as lethargic as ever
completely unphased by what was going on
it certainly seemed that when it rained
it really poured in this new house just
as he was searching for his missing
hamster Milo heard a new horrible sound
echo through the corridors this one
wasn't so much a scary noise even if it
did make him jump but it was more the
inconvenience that came with it finally
giving out after God knows how many
years it had been installed for The
house's boiler burst spending the
afternoon into the evening failing to
track down one of his Missing Pets and
stopping the huge ironcast boiler from
flooding the basement wasn't exactly
what Milo had in mind for fun activities
to do when he got home going to bed
frustrated made it as hard to sleep as
all the nightly cacophony of creaking
floorboards and branches raking against
the windows he tapped out two of the
pills the doctor had prescribed him
knocking them back with a sharp motion
of his head and a swig of cold water
before laying back in bed as night had
fallen the temperature also had
plummeted too not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn't
stop himself from shivering in the cold
his forming clouds in front of his face
he reached for the knitted blanket and
threw it over himself curling up
underneath it to try and provide an
extra layer of warmth to protect himself
from the gnawing cold the pills did as
they were meant to helping Milo to
quickly sleep into a much deeper sleep
than he had experienced in a while
although it didn't seem to help the
nightmares Mr and Mrs Shaw came back
again this time they had Milo's arms and
legs tied up with their matching
disapproving faces the elderly couple
threw threw something over their
helpless victim and tried to smother him
to death for a dream it felt so intense
so real Milo could feel a heavy weight
on top of his body as he slept in fact
it felt like it was all around him
engulfing and crushing the life out of
him from all sides but it was the
feeling of something wet against his arm
the sensation of liquid against his skin
and the numbness where his hand should
be were what finally pulled him out of
the dream and into the nightmare through
the dark and his cloudy vision Milo
could see a wide gaping ma filled with
teeth the feeling of being crushed was
still surrounding him and despite
kicking his legs and trying to free
himself from confinement it didn't stop
squeezing him tighter his Panic was
already making it harder to catch his
breath but now he could barely fill his
lungs enough to scream for help not that
anyone was around to hear him but it was
the sight of his arm that chilled Milo's
blood it wasn't there anymore part of it
just above the elbow was just gone his
hand hand fingers every internal bone
and muscle had been reduced to a bloody
mess a slurry of red melting and coming
apart it was runny little more than a
liquid resembling the consistency of
sand when it's underwater and becomes
sludge most of his flesh was liquified
going further up his arm and as the
blanket pulled its prey into its mouth
until Milo was no more not a trace of
him left just like the previous owners
little did Milo or the Shaws and donut
before him know but he'd been the victim
of a creature that was part of a rather
unique species while they will often
vary in size shape pattern and other
aspects of their appearance SCP 799
always seemed to be ordinary items of
knitted bed wear at least at first they
retain heat like a normal blanket wood
and are soft to the touch and for the
most part don't seem directly harmful
and usually they aren't SCP 799 are
incapable of much movement instead
laying still a lot of time not unlike a
certain bearded dragon that just lost
its owner they also don't seem to
require much in the way of food
extracting with little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter in dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered mouths in the fibers however
this changes if an SCP 799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
will they possess this biological trait
that themselves SCP 799 don't seem to
regard coldblooded animals to be the
source of food in fact they don't even
seem to be able to detect other
creatures with cold blood such as
reptiles instead SCP 799 will
metamorphose into a more predatory form
in order to consume any warm-blooded
mammal or human being it encounters
transforming its feeding orifices and
digestive tract into a singular mouth
lined with several rolls of sharp
pointed teeth from there it will wrap up
the largest warm-blooded animal it can
find whether that be a hamster or a
grown man and will tear off parts of its
prey reducing them to little more than a
thin slurry as it digests their body
mass to feed itself so if you move into
a new house and come across an old
knitted blanket maybe consider throwing
it out if you want to live we all have
fond memories of the playground hours
upon hours spent in Blissful childhood
abandon in racing around the local park
climbing the monkey bars and seeing if
you could get even higher on the swings
than your best friend and then of course
there's the slide who doesn't love a
slide only you and the force of gravity
pulling you down through a straight or
spiral tube those few seconds of
excitement that Rush of not knowing
whether you'll come out the other end of
the slide or not that's enough of a
thrill for any kid of course you would
always come tumbling out of the m mouth
of the slide every time at worst with an
odd but innocent friction burn on your
leg or arm but what if one day you
didn't come out of the other end or
Worse what if the place at the end of
the slide wasn't the world you left
behind when you slid through the
entrance it doesn't seem all that likely
to happen right well you've obviously
never taken a trip down SCP
1562 better known as the tunnel slide as
its moniker suggests SCP 1562 is a slide
or it at least appears to be an ordinary
tunnel slide you know the kind that you
would easily find at any kids park
jungle gym or indoor play area just over
2 m high and almost 3 and 1/2 M long and
for the most part it is a completely
normal slide if you were to just sit in
it and glide down it feet first nothing
would happen then again if SCP 156 2 was
an ordinary everyday piece of a
playground then the SCP Foundation would
not have such a vested interest in it
they definitely wouldn't be keeping it
locked up in quarantine secured in
Testing Lab 46- V of site 24 and if any
foundation agents ask you didn't hear
that from us by the way the door to the
lab is kept locked at all times no
member of personnel is even allowed near
the slide unless granted special
clearance to do so by Foundation
research Dr Carver so what is it that
makes this thing so special well for one
SCP 1562 was first recovered by the
foundation from a defunct abandoned
playground the location of this
playground has been redacted but it was
known to be on the outskirts of a town
where a number of young children had
been reported missing does SCP 1562
contain some sort of clue as to where
these children were taken perhaps some
piece of forensic evidence left behind
by a child snatching anomaly from
another Di mention not quite SCP 1562 is
the thing that took those children you
see the slides anomalous properties
require very specific circumstances in
order to activate like we mentioned
earlier if you were just sitting on your
butt while you were sliding down it you
would Escape unscathed laying flat on
your back that is also a safe option
even flailing yourself about spinning
and rolling and waving your arms
changing position on the way down would
mean that nothing anomalous would appear
to happen however if someone enters SCP
1562 and travels down in head first
laying on their stomach with their arms
tucked at their side almost in a plank
position then that is when strange
things start to happen that is when a
person finds out what happened to those
missing children only about 15 cm from
the opening of the slide a person
sliding down on their front head first
With Arms by their sides will disappear
right before exiting as CP
1562 in an instant they will simply be
gone no longer in the slide or even
relocated to anywhere nearby to make
matters worse every single person that
this has happened to has never been
found again they literally have vanished
off the face of the Earth unfortunately
there isn't much that can be done to
prevent this during testing the
foundation quickly learned that
tethering a safety line to a subject
does little to stop them from
disappearing they can not be pulled back
from wherever it is that the slide sends
them the Rope they are attached to is
simply cut and goes slack from the
moment that a person is taken by the
slide now that sounds like the whole
story right children are going missing
and the foundation learns it's because
of SCP
1562 some kind of interdimensional
portal within a playground slide so they
acquire the slide take it away and keep
it locked up securely where it can't
cause any more disappearances end of
story
except that's not quite the end no the
one thing it's still possible to do once
someone has disappeared down the slide
is to stay in contact with them the SCP
Foundation has expended a number of test
subjects by sending them sliding down
SCP 1562 just to learn what's on the
other side just where does the slide
take them luckily tests like this are
precisely what the foundation has
d-class Personnel for so what happened
when the foundation sent some d classes
on a one-way joy ride down the slide
well one test involved a d-class
designated
d2445 who disappeared into SCP 1562 but
was given a two-way radio to communicate
directly with Dr derrett one of the
research staff d2445 reported that he
felt himself in a small cramped tunnel
and quickly requested to be let back out
Dr Jarrett had neglected to tell d2445
that was impossible and that no one ever
came back from in inside the slide while
it was too dark to see anything The
Prisoner described still being laid on
his front but feeling like there were
rocks or dirt surrounding him on all
sides realizing that he barely had
enough room to move or even lift his
head d2445 again requested to be let out
of SCP
1562 as the unfortunate d-class grew
increasingly more unsettled by the
movement restricting environment Dr
darrs revealed that the lifeline
tethering d2445 back to the foundation
had been severed upon their
disappearance into the slide panicking
d2445 managed to move forward slightly
and realized that his head had hit
something a shoe a tiny child's shoe
communication with d2445 was called to a
halt and the foundation's researchers
discussed possible ways that they could
retrieve the prisoner although most of
them probably knew at this point that
this task was likely impossible this
test may have taken place before the
foundation realized that return from SCP
1562 was impossible the plan was that
another d-class would be sent into the
slide once again they would be attached
to a tether line and be carrying video
and audio recording equipment along with
a GPS tracker and a headlamp reaching
out to d2445 Dr darrett relayed this
plan to him d2445 immediately begged to
be set free from SCP
1562 as the doctor attempted to calm him
down but too little a fact something had
scared him truly terrified him a sound
coming from somewhere within the tunnel
it started talking d2445 claimed when Dr
darrett asked for clarity the d-class
replied saying that a little boy had
tried to speak to him but that the child
had made little sense he just kept
asking where he was and I told him I
didn't know but I don't think he was
really talking to me because he didn't
respond to my voice and he told me to
stop crying when I was actually sort of
calm when asked if this child had moved
at all d2445 said that he was unsure he
started screaming and I told him to shut
up but he just kept screaming and crying
and asking for his mommy and then he
finally stopped and shortly after that
you contacted me again please get me out
now Dr darrett tried to reassure the man
to little Avail and communication with
d2445 was cut off after he claimed
something was wrong with his chest
shortly after the foundation lost
communication with
d2445 another member of d-class was sent
into the slide after him this subject
referred to officially SD 8600 had been
specifically selected for this task
thanks to his small stature Dr darrett
and the other Foundation researchers
testing SCP 1562 believed that the man's
thinner body type would allow d86 to
better navigate the tunnel that the
slides seemed to transport people to and
you can probably guess what happened
next just just like all the others that
had been sent down the slide d86 was
trapped his Lifeline was cut the moment
that he vanished inside the tunnel slide
on top of this the GPS tracker that this
thinner d-class had been issued with
seemed to not be working properly its
signal could not be correctly traced and
without an accurate fix there was no way
to determine the location to which SCP
1562 was transporting its victims if it
was even in this universe additionally
the video feed from the camera d86 was
carrying also failed to connect with
only audio from his radio being
recovered by the research team
contacting
d86 Dr darrett was informed by this new
d-class that his headlamp had stopped
working the second he had arrived in the
same cave or tunnel as earlier test
subjects before long by shimmying
through the area on his arms d86 bumped
into a foot believed to be belonging to
d2445 well he could barely see anything
d86 could hear d2445 is voice and this
was being faintly picked up via His
Radio however as he and Dr darrett tried
to talk to the first prisoner his words
began to sound all too familiar I don't
know some sort of very small tunnel it's
really cramped can you get me out now
followed by no it's it's too dark I
can't see anything and I'm stuck it was
all just a recording from what
d2445 had said when he first arrived
after s DP 1562 had sent him into the
tunnel d86 did not realize this at first
and attempted to help his fellow
prisoner hoping to pull him out of
wherever they were trapped Dr darrett
tried desperately to explain that d2445
was just repeating his half of an
earlier conversation but D 8600 hardly
noticed that was the case he gripped the
other DCL class's ankles and told the
doctor to pull them out of the tunnel
the doctor revealed that once again the
tether line had been severed but but D
8600 refused to believe that escape was
impossible he tried to worm his way back
the way he had come leaving d2445 still
repeating his words from earlier he just
kept asking me where he was and I told
him I didn't know but I don't think he
was really talking to me because he
didn't respond to my voice and he told
me to stop crying when I was actually
sort of calm I don't think so he started
screaming and I told him to shut up but
he kept just screaming and crying and
asking for his mommy then he finally
stopped and shortly after that yuk
detected me again please get me out now
please hurry my chest is really starting
to hurt after yelling at him to stop
talking multiple times d86 noted that
d2445 had finally gone quiet the d-class
also remarked that the air was starting
to taste stale and hope that there would
be enough oxygen for him to get back
then just like his predecessor
communication with d8 600 came to an
abrupt stop Dr jarretts was no longer
able to reach him on the radio there was
nothing but static the foundation was
unable to reestablish contact with
either of the two d-class Personnel lost
inside SCP
1562 and any future testing of the
tunnel slide was suspended to this day
none of us know what exactly happened to
the victims of the tunnel slide where
were they taken what had taken them what
was making the prior victims repeat
their ominous words as horror author
Stephen King once put it it's the
unanswered questions that stays with us
the longest but the next time you decide
to Thrill your inner child by taking a
jean to your local Kitty Park you may
just find out for yourself obviously it
helps to be an animal lover when you
start working at a shelter it's not
exactly a requirement of the job but it
definitely makes it a little more
palatable when you occasionally have to
deal with a critter that's more nasty
than usual having an already built-in
compassion towards animals makes it
easier to forgive them for not doing
what you want
from a very young age Harper always
liked to think of animals as people they
just didn't think or communicate the
same way as humans even the best trained
pets in the world don't really know the
actual meaning of certain words they're
just taught how to respond to specific
commands in certain ways but that
doesn't mean they couldn't also have
distinct personalities of their own just
like humans do and then of course there
were all the wild animals that had never
been trained or domesticated
Harper always felt a little sorry for
any baby bird with its wing broken or
any badgers or posum that arrived at the
shelter after getting hit by a car they
didn't live around humans and had
probably never even experienced being
indoors before let alone having people
nursing them back to health to empathize
Harper used to imagine how terrified she
would be if she was hurt if she'd broken
her leg or arm or Worse only for
something much larger than her to take
her into a structure she'd never been in
before and on top of that having no way
of understanding that this giant was
trying to help her heal as well as being
separated from her friends family and
everyone she knew the way she saw it
this was what it must have been like for
the majority of animals that were
brought into the shelter where she
worked and she wanted to do her best to
help calm her little furry or feathered
patience you got to fortify your heart
in this job harp her friends who worked
with her at the shelter would say and it
was true to an extent they didn't mean
she'd have to become cold and heartless
that would be an overcorrection but it
was their and Harper's responsibility to
administer the appropriate Medical Care
and provide a temporary Sanctuary to
these lost wounded or abandoned animals
what Harper had to remember was that
none of them were her own pets often a
lot of the critters that were brought
into the shelter were already someone
else's companion and might have just got
lost while while out on a walk and while
some others were given up by their
previous owners who had cruy Shrugged
off the responsibility of caring for
them those animals were in need of new
homes and couldn't stay cooped up in the
shelter forever not everyone that gave
up their pet did it callously though
sometimes they might have found
themselves falling on hard times and
being unable to financially look after
an animal others might have owned a pet
that had a behavioral problem like being
too aggressive and even though the
person still loved them dearly they
might have just not been able to make it
work in times like that they'd have no
choice but to take their animal to the
shelter just outside the side entrance
was an area where people could drop off
their animals and quickly Buzz to the
staff inside just in case they wanted to
avoid a protracted emotional farewell to
their four-legged or winged companion
the buzzer had sounded just as Harper
had been coming off for lunch break it
was her turn this shift to quickly go
and collect any animal that had been
left out there even though their owners
usually left them in their cage or with
their lead tied to a nearby Street Lamp
Harper knew she had to rush to the side
door just in case somebody else tried to
rush in and steal the poor abandoned pet
after turning them in the lock she
hooked her keys back on the belt clip
she wore and pushed the side door open
Harper had been fully expecting to see
the usual a leash dog or cat coming over
to investigate her confused as to where
their former owner had gone this time
though there was just a box standing
outside it wasn't huge in fact it was
almost entirely empty almost picking it
up carefully in case there were baby
birds or a nest of unhatched eggs inside
Harper opened the cardboard flap to
reveal a rock sitting in the Box was a
single solitary Rock an oval of smooth
Granite with a paper note next to it
reaching in she retrieved and unfolded
the scrap please care for my pet rock
was written on one inside in a messy
uncoordinated scrawl immediately
assuming that this whole thing was some
kid's idea of a joke Harper tipped the
rock out onto the ground and threw the
box in the trash she had more important
things to focus on within the next hour
alone people brought in a concussed
parakeet a bat infected with rabies and
a squirrel that had survived being run
over by a moped into the shelter work
had been so busy that by the time her
shift had ended Harper had barely
thought about the pet rock prank that is
until she was getting ready to leave she
headed through the side door mainly so
that she could do a final check in case
any animals had been left there and
someone had forgotten to hit the buzzer
there was nothing there and Harper
hooked her bag over her shoulder
shutting the door behind her something
the size and weight of a baseball
knocked against her foot causing her to
look down and see the rock the same one
from earlier only now it had flipped
over probably after she had tipped it
out of its box on the side facing up at
her The Rock had a shiny metal zipper
fastened shut curious Harper picked it
up to take a closer look it didn't seem
like the zip had just been glued onto
the stone surface it was embedded in it
actually part of the rock itself and
there was something sad about it sure it
was just a rock an inanimate lump of
stone but for whatever reason a feeling
of pity crept up on Harper causing her
to slip the rock into her bag as she
headed for the parking lot it was
starting to get dark by the time she got
home heading up to her room and flipping
on her lamp Harper placed the zipped up
Stone under its light and took another
long look at it although she'd first
thought it was purely a joke now she
couldn't tell if it was some elaborate
art piece or a quirky Garden ornament
the thing was solid Stone all the way
through surely the Zipper was just for
show there couldn't possibly be anything
beneath it to her surprise the metal
Fastener began to part as Harper dragged
on the puller and slider down from the
top stop towards the bottom one it was
relatively easy not even some of her own
clothes unzipped as smoothly as this
rock as soon as the slider connected
with the bottom stop the teeth of the
top and bottom edges parted revealing
more teeth below except these almost
looked like human teeth they opened up
to reveal a mouth a part of the rock
just like the zipper which took the
place of its lips the moment the mouth
opened let out a tiny sound like it was
breathing which startled Harper with a
Yelp she dropped the Rock from her hands
and it even made a tiny grunt as it fell
to the floor it was alive seeing it hit
her bedroom carpet Harper stared utterly
bewildered at the Rock its toothy mouth
almost looked sad like it had curved
into a frown then she heard the sound it
was making perhaps it was her years
working with animals at the shelter and
her long- held sympathy for them that
had had given her a sort of protective
Instinct for all living things or maybe
it was just the bizarreness of the
situation of having a rock with a mouth
whimpering in pain on the floor in front
of her either way Harper felt compelled
to pick the lump of stone back up and
place it gently on the desk its mouth
seemed to smile a bit more as she did
while it seemed creepy at first the
compulsion to take care of this helpless
Little Rock only got stronger grabbing a
pipet and pouring a glass of water from
the faucet Harper started to squeeze out
droplets of water into the Rock's mouth
she had no idea how it was able to drink
but that didn't seem at all important or
relevant in order for her to care for it
after all every time a parrot or duck or
Crow was brought into the station the
procedure was similar Harper would have
to pipet them water or medicine it
didn't matter how they drank it just
because they had beaks it was the same
with baby animals puppies and kittens
especially who might need bottle feeding
if they were only only a few weeks old
as much as she was starting from scratch
and would normally be completely baffled
as to the best ways she could care for
the Rock right now Harper was pulling on
her experience at the shelter to nurse
it back to health if she was in fact
using her instincts and not being
influenced somehow over the next few
days Harper looked after her Newfound
patient as if it had been her lifelong
pet as to why she was taking such care
of a rock or even what she would
eventually do with it Harper didn't
really have much of a clue but the
answer to those questions didn't feel as
important as looking after the rock
she'd leave for work in the morning only
to count down the hours through her
shift until she got to go home and tend
to The Smiling Stone throughout the
course of her working day she would
pocket supplies to help her take better
care of her new pet everything from
medicine in case it got sick or picked
up an infection of some kind to bandages
and other materials she could use as
beding grabbing a fresh clean plastic
container for it instead of another
cardboard box Harper was gradually
fashioning a nest for the toothy Pebble
and for the most part it seemed to be
working some deep-seated feeling told
her that her efforts to look after the
rock was gradually making it feel better
every day and then it started talking it
wasn't exactly articulate or eloquent it
didn't even seem to know that many words
other than the two it was weekly
repeating when she came home from work
one day me eat eat it rasped a horse
whisper passing through its unzipped
lips rushing over to it barely
questioning it Harper tried filling up
her pipet and giving it more water The
Rock spat it back out before speaking
again no drink only
eight what what do I need to feed you
she asked only again not questioning the
absurdity of talking to a rock maybe
after this point after getting over the
fact it had a mouth it wasn't much of a
shock that that the stone also had a
voice or could her compelling need to
care for it make her oblivious to the
strangeness of this situation of course
this wasn't a situation that many people
had also found themselves in this meant
that even a quick cursory internet
search for what do pet rocks eat didn't
yield many useful results only a few
joke articles and nothing that actually
gave Harper an answer she could act on
all the while her Rock was still
croaking out the same two words
repeating them on a loop its little
voice getting more and more forceful
each time need eat need eat low on
options Harper left some bread crusts in
The Rock's Nest hoping that would be
enough to at least satiate the Rock's
obvious hunger it paused either smelling
or sensing that it had been offered
something to eat feed it rasps before
opening its mouth wide with a tiny
expectant picking up the crusts one by
one Harper broke little pieces off and
fed each bit to a rock she sighed as a
sense of overwhelming relief came
flooding over her glad that she'd found
a way to feed the mouthy little mineral
if only it had worked for longer only a
few hours later Harper was met with more
scraping demands from her pet rock the
insistent sound waking her up in the
middle of the night but this time as she
offered it more bread scraps it refused
to eat them it was still the early hours
of the morning by the time that Harper
had gotten through offering the rock
every different type of food in her
kitchen eventually giving up through
sheer exhaustion she folded her pillow
over her ears trying to drown out the
constant cries of need eat but it didn't
do enough to allow her to get to sleep
at any rate the feeling that she had to
care for this talking Rock was keeping
her awake as much as the noise staring
across the room purposely facing away
from her pet rock Harper's eyes fell
over her work uniform the logo of the
animal shelter stitched on it was just
about visible as the gentle glow of
Street lamps bled through the curtains
and seeing it along with her keys
clipped onto her belt that lay on the
floor gave her an idea that might work
desperation and the need to sleep
getting the better of her Harper climbed
in the car having put a jacket and jeans
over her pajamas the streets were all
empty at this hour almost pitch dark and
deathly silent but it made driving from
her home to her workplace a lot faster
than usual all the while The Rock's
voice was getting more and more
demanding from its container that she
had strapped to the front passenger seat
sneaking up to the side door Harper
turned her key in the lock pulled it
open and slipped in doors the moment
they heard the sound of the door
shutting a number of the dogs that had
been resting securely in their cages
woke up and started barking the noise
loudly echoing around the shelter even
though it drowned Out The Rock's tiny
voice it felt as if its words were still
ringing in Harper's ears compelling her
to go through with something she really
didn't want to and yet it felt like one
of the only other options she had left
she decided it would have to be the
squirrel rationalizing the choice in her
head in an unpleasant but purely
calculated logic based way it made the
most sense earlier that week the bushy
tailed Woodland forager had been hit by
a moped it had barely survived given the
number of its tiny bones that had been
broken in the force of the impact
finding its cage it was still asleep
heavily sedated on the dosage of paint
Killers the shelter's resident vet had
given it gently scooping it out of the
cage feeling its fur against her cued
hand Harper looked at her pet rock its
container on the table she remembered
that it liked to be fed directly
swallowing an urge to be sick that was
rising at the back of her throat Harper
opened a drawer in the vet's office and
pulled out a surgical scalpel when her
boss at the shelter heard there had been
a break-in and reviewed the footage on
the building security cameras they were
shocked at what they saw though the
angle scared what Harper was doing the
blood left over and one missing squirrel
seemed to be enough to go on that
coupled with the fact that she had
broken in after hours and the numerous
supplies that had gone missing from the
storage cupboard led to Harper being
dismissed she was fired from her job at
the animal shelter forced to hand over
her keys and uniform while any other day
this would have devastated her the
events seemed to wash over Harper pretty
quickly she was more relieved no pleased
with herself that The Rock had stopped
begging her to be fed her plan had
worked for now it took about a week for
her pet rock to start demanding food
again this time just the sound of its
voice made Harper frantic any ordinary
human food she offered wasn't enough it
didn't want that she already knew
exactly what it wanted the only thing
she'd fed it that had sustained it the
big problem was that now she didn't have
her keys it would be near impossible for
her to get into the shelter again yet
still the forceful command to be fed
kept up day and night hour after hour
until Harper considered the only thing
she had left to give her pet rock
lifting it out of the warm Nest she kept
it in her fingers were gripping the
smooth Stone tightly her arm was tense
in fact both were one of her muscles
strained while she held the rock the
other in anticipation hovering it above
her opposite arm Harper could feel the
tiny breaths of her pet against her skin
almost like it was so excited to eat
again that it was panting with
expectancy she put it back down on her
desk quickly running into the bathroom
it wasn't that she had changed her mind
she couldn't all she knew was that she
had to feed her pet rock Harper just
needed to grab a cloth to put it in her
mouth clamping her Jaws down on it to
muffle her scream as she let the Rock's
teeth sink into her Flesh Blood
trickling down her arm nobody saw much
of Harper afterwards her friends from
the shelter would continuously call her
cell phone only to get no reply she
barely paid any attention to the ringing
eventually just letting her phone
batteries die and not even bothering to
charge it back up it wasn't important to
her the only thing that mattered was
caring for her pet rock in Harper's head
it needed to be kept safe and fed and it
was her job to look after it to the best
of her ability she had enough left over
medical supplies that she lifted from
the shelter bandages antiseptic spray
rubbing alcohol tranquilizers to treat
her wounds after a while it almost
stopped hurting knowing that she was
helping keep her pet rock fed being so
emotionally attached to it made all of
the pain more bearable even when she
woke up one morning to find that her
Rock had rolled off her desk onto her
bed it hardly faced her nor did seeing
that it had gradually eaten her leg
during the night gnawing through tendons
and bone as she slept leaving her Sheets
still slick with blood when she awoke
despite having lost most of her capacity
for rational thought Harper decided it
would be best to plan ahead for when she
was gone she knew through some Twisted
form of logic that she wasn't going to
last forever there was only so much of
her she'd be able to feed her pet rock
for so long Harper held a pen in her
hand as best she could with all the
fingers she was now missing she scrolled
out a note whoever found what was left
of her in messy uncoordinated
handwriting please care for my pet rock
not everything in this world is exactly
as it seems in fact there are many
creatures in the wild that go out of
their way to be deceptive to disguise
themselves as something entirely
different from their true nature
aggressive mimicry refers to a
phenomenon in which Predators or
parasites take on the appearance of
something harmless or even appealing in
order to lure in their intended prey or
host without detection they might
resemble food an inanimate part of the
environment or even a potential m at
whatever they choose they're secretly a
wolf in sheep's clothing in the deep
dark Waters of the ocean the angler fish
dangles an alluring light from its head
ushering in little fish that it can trap
in its mouth and devour whole the
alligator snapping turtle Wiggles its
long tongue like a worm attracting
Hungry Fish looking for their next meal
instead they become the meal for
something bigger and more clever than
them false cleaner fish share their
appearance of another species while that
helps clean larger fish in a symbiotic
relationship when the imposters find a
victim they swim close under the
pretense of cleaning only to take a bite
out of them and swim away Predators use
similar illusions on land 2 anti-
mimicking jumping spiders wave their
false antenna in the air in an imitation
of an ant's movements isolating the
insects from their colony before
dragging them back to their Lair to be
devoured the mouth parts of the male
spiders are shaped like the head of an
ant but this imitation head splits apart
to reveal the spider's fangs and its
true intentions the fotorus Firefly
lights up its body in a mimicry of other
Firefly species mating signals signaling
male fireflies looking for companionship
when they respond to the call however
they will not find a willing mate
waiting but instead a fem fatal of a
firefly that just wants to eat the
spider tailed horn Viper has a bulbous
tip on its tail with false legs jutting
out on either side
as the snake Wiggles its tail running it
across the ground while the rest of its
body lies in weight just out of sight a
hungry bird spots it from above when the
bird swoops down to seize the
opportunity the snake reveals itself
snapping up the unfortunate bird before
it can escape thankfully humans are so
much smarter and more observant than
fish ants and birds we're safe from that
sort of trickery there aren't any
animals out there who've learned how to
look like something familiar something
every day just to put unsuspecting
people at ease and lure us into its
waiting Jaws right wrong only a couple
of years ago the SCP Foundation
discovered a being that has mastered
aggressive mimicry on a level previously
unseen in the natural world
unfortunately for us its prey of choice
happens to be humans and its hunting
ground is the very cities where we like
to think we're safe from something much
bigger meaner and hungrier than us a
short video went viral on a popular
social media platform the specific
platform has been redacted from official
files but the details of it are clear a
popular Creator on the app a young woman
known for her makeup tutorials and
restaurant recommendations around her
native city of Los Angeles she was live
streaming and answering questions while
going about her day when she stepped
onto a train at one of the Metro
stations around the city the train was
extremely crowded and she was preparing
to end the live video planning to resume
once she reached her destination but
just as she went to pressed the button
at the end of the stream something
strange happened the train went dark and
the space flooded with a strange thick
liquid the girl screamed in either pain
horror or both and dropped the phone
whatever it fell into must have degraded
the phone at an extremely rapid Pace
because the video feed cut out
immediately after a splash all across
social media people shared the video
with one question in mind what happened
on that train fans mounted a campaign to
find the influencer to help her if she
was in any immediate danger but there
were no leads her friends and family
said she never came home that day and
when authorities attempted to trace her
phone they could not get any kind of
signal becoming increasingly concerned
about this missing girl and the
possibility of some kind of unreported
train accident authorities contacted the
Los Angeles metro and showed them the
video footage but every train was
accounted for and in pristine condition
there had been no strange chemical leaks
no crashes
and certainly nothing like what the
video appeared to show at the same time
there were missing persons reports being
filed all across the country in every
area with a thriving public
transportation system not only were the
occupants of the Los Angeles train
unaccounted for with no wreckage or
bodies to be found but people were
disappearing in train stations in New
York Boston Chicago Washington DC and
more a woman reported her husband
missing after he called her to check in
during his daily commute home from work
the train had kept going for much longer
than it ordinarily did drifting off of
its usual route he told her that
something was wrong that he had a
terrible feeling of for boing and then
the call cut off he never made it home
for dinner a young woman was on her way
to start an internship at a prestigious
New York City magazine but never arrived
for her first meeting when her wouldbe
boss reached out to the girl's roommate
all he knew was that she had planned to
take the train to work that morning a
private detective trailing a man's wife
for him looking for evidence of an
affair lost track of her when she
stepped onto a train downtown he took
the next train hoping to catch her at
what he assumed would be her stop but
she never got off he wasn't able to
track her down and had to give her
suspicious husband the news that his
wife had somehow vanished Into Thin Air
it wasn't just one or two people every
so often either entire train cars of
people were just disappearing never to
be seen again no matter how hard anyone
tried they could not find any answers no
logical explanation for what could have
happened fortunately the video
circulated so widely that it made it
onto the feed of an SCP Foundation
employee who was idly scrolling during a
bathroom break he was so shocked by what
he saw that he almost forgot to pull up
his pants before running out into the
Hall fortunately he did remember and
rushed to his supervisor's office fully
clothed after determining that the video
was not a hoax or some kind of viral
marketing stunt intended to sell a new
brand of spicy chips the SCP Foundation
decided to launch a formal investigation
into anomalous activity involving trains
and subway systems around the country
task forces were set up in every major
city and field researchers were assigned
to take the train all day every day as
much as possible as they did they would
maintain communication with the head of
their task force would monitor their
findings via hidden cameras and
microphones a week passed without
incident and the foundation was starting
to wonder if somehow the Los Angeles
video had been faked when the Chicago
task force made a harrowing Discovery
officer Jamie Bower was assigned to
monitor the trains on Chicago's Blue
Line taking the train throughout the day
and keeping an eye out for suspicious or
potentially anomalous Activity one week
in and he pretty much had it down to a
basic routine he would grab breakfast
hop on the train and enjoy his coffee
and meal while reading a book and
writing the train to its last stop then
he'd pick up lunch and do the same thing
all over again he'd have dinner and
repeat it wasn't too exciting but then
again excitement in this case probably
meant Horrors Beyond his comprehension
so he was perfectly fine with traversing
the city in a subway car and catching up
on the backlog of murder mysteries he'd
been meaning to read it was Monday
afternoon he' picked up a slice of deep
dish pizza excited to try it for the
first time and walked down into the
metro station as he took his first bite
can you try not to chew into your
microphone please it's gross Dr Susan
shepher the head of the Chicago task
force spoke into Jim's earpiece you got
it boss he said his mouth full thanks
see anything unusual today she asked you
tell me you can see the video feed right
he took another bite chewing as quietly
as he could sure but you're on the
ground just keep an eye out okay be
careful remember to draw your weapon if
something goes south don't just
disappear into your book and forget to
keep your wits about you Dr Shephard
side yep getting on the train now not
going to talk much so these folks don't
think think I'm nuts jimie waited for
the doors to open and just for a moment
noticed that they seemed to stick just a
little this time nothing to be too
worried about though everything looked
normal just as it had on every other
ride he'd taken he could feel the Agatha
chrisy book calling to him from inside
of his tote bag and he wanted to crack
it open and see what Clues heru quo had
come across but Dr Shephard was right
he'd been slacking off he needed to pay
attention to his surroundings so he did
just that he watched as the train car
steadily filled up with passengers
college students with bags full of books
and exhausted Expressions middle-age
people in business attire tourists
wearing souvenir baseball caps and
snapping pictures of everything in sight
before too long the train was completely
packed and Jamie could barely move
without bumping elbows with someone it
was a little claustrophobic but that was
public transportation Jaimie leaned back
in his seat pulled his book out and
focused on the comforting Rumble of the
engine the Rhythm Of The Wheels On The
Tracks suddenly without warning the
train screeched to a stop they were in
the middle of a tunnel Jamie assumed
from the darkness that flanked them out
the window on either side wait was it
dark or had the windows just disappeared
he squinted through the Blackness and
tried to see what was outside but he
couldn't make sense of his surroundings
all around the other passengers were
becoming Restless nervous some were
calling for help others were just
complaining doc you seeing this Jamie
hissed into the microphone I don't see a
thing Dr Shephard replied are you all
right fine the Train's just stalled I
don't know where or what's wrong with it
Jamie began feeling along the walls of
the train looking for doors huh that's
weird what well the crack in the doors
when they come together should be right
here but it's all smooth no gaps or
anything like it's all one thing and it
feels strange like he cut himself off as
his stomach dropped a sudden Rush of
fear flooding his senses like what Dr
Shephard pressed like it's alive Jamie
said shakely Campbell what's happening
in there Dr Shephard began taking
Furious notes on her end I don't know
it's so dark everyone's scared I'm
scared I don't think this is a train I
don't know what it is but it's nothing
good as Jamie felt around he smelled
something sour foul and sharp in his
nose he heard liquid splashing onto the
ground the sound of something sizzling
and then people started to scream as he
felt along the wall something dripped
onto his hand and then it started to
burn he cried out in agony as whatever
had dripped onto him ate away at the
skin dissolving his hand bit by bit what
is it Dr Shepherd's voice shook as she
heard the pain in Jam's voice some kind
of acid oh God it's everywhere it's on
the walls floors it just keeps coming he
trailed off oh God oh God we're in his
stomach whatever this thing is it's
eating us Campbell you need to get out
of there right now Dr sheeper ordered
draw your weapon whatever you need to do
just get out Jamie pulled out his weapon
and started firing at the place where
the doors should be but the bullets
bounced off uselessly as if the fleshy
material was the side of a tank he fired
until there was no more ammunition left
and then he just kept squeezing the
trigger some more out of pure survival
Instinct but all it got him was a
useless click and the certainty that the
one thing he had brought with him in
case of emergency was completely useless
all the while the acid was creeping
higher dripping from every surface
filling the train car until it swallowed
the cries for help and this screams of
fear and Agony all Dr Shepard could do
was listen helpless as jimie and the
rest of the passengers were digested
inside of the massive stomach what
happened to officer Jamie Campbell was
tragic but it provided important
information that the foundation would
likely never have gotten otherwise they
now knew a few key things about this new
anomaly it was some kind of living thing
able to disguise itself as a train it
was resilient to bullets and firearms
and it was hiding in plain sight in in
order to hunt human beings they had
found the culprit for the rash of
mysterious disappearances and it was a
race of unidentified creatures capable
of taking on the shape of a common
underground train the new found
information quickly circulated
throughout the foundation making its way
to the various task forces assigned to
operation Metro as it had been
unofficially nicknamed task force
members were no longer instructed to
board trains instead they would slip
hidden cameras onto as many train cars
as they possibly could
each outfitted with a tracking device
then the foundation could remotely
monitor the trains for any potential
signs of the mysterious creatures
looking for imposters masquerading as
trains without unnecessarily losing any
more operatives in action now as for
what they would do once they found one
of these massive creatures was still
uncertain but at least they had
somewhere to start the SCP Foundation
tried and failed to contain several
instances of the carnivorous species
before they finally got it right they
attempted to free freeze the inside of
one train with liquid nitrogen hoping to
incapacitate the creature before it
could feed defend itself or Escape
custody the extreme cold seemed to have
no effect however and the false train
slammed its doors shut at the first sign
of discomfort then sped away at high
speed as it did the task force members
noticed that though they could hear the
sound of wheels on the tracks they could
see legs jutting out of the bottom of
the creature scuttling along the ground
next they attempted to take out the
creature's legs and render it mobile so
that it could be subdued the legs were
resilient to external damage becoming
hard as a rock whenever any weapon blade
or other Implement made contact with
them one Task Force member tried to
physically hold some of the legs in
place but they shifted their shape
becoming appendages resembling tentacles
and threw the man out of the way before
the false train hurried out of the
tunnel and out of sight they were then
able to track down a predatory train
just after a feeding when it was
slightly sluggish after a large meal
they pumped an aerosolized poison into
the Train's interior the belly of the
Beast potent enough to take out a
dinosaur and were relieved to find that
the creature was unable to flee
unfortunately though they were able to
subdue the creature they killed it in
the process at first they assumed it was
just inactive but it never resumed
activity again it was just like an
ordinary train car almost when the
interior was touched it felt warm and
slightly pliable less like metal and
plastic and more like flesh the longer
the creature was still the more the
windows on the side stopped looking like
Windows and started looking like wide
glassy eyes the front of the train
became a gaping maw the silhouette of
the conductor inside revealed as an
extension of the creature's body
resembling a Tong survivors and
Witnesses were given an amnestic to
remove any memories of the supposed
killer trains running under their city
and the foundation prepared to bring the
dead specimen in for further study a
cover story was used involving massive
of repairs to the train system and while
the tunnels were closed off they managed
to remove the creature and transport it
to a nearby Foundation containment site
there it was given one of the most
extensive autopsies in Foundation
history and the first one conducted
largely from inside the subject the
autopsy provided a more in-depth look at
the nature of the bizarre creature and
its curious nature the creature
nicknamed the train eater referring to
its preferred disguise and favored
activity was one of an apparent species
of carnivorous predators that use
shape-shifting and an advanced form of
aggressive mimicry to prey on commuters
tourists and anyone else in need of a
ride from one place to the next it would
mimic the shape feel and sounds of a
train welcoming unassuming victims into
its stomach and once it was completely
full and able to efficiently feed it
would release an incredibly potent
stomach acid into the compartment and
quickly dissolve everything inside the
creature was highly adaptable a able to
harden parts of its body at will and
display extreme resilience to weapons of
any kind due to this nearly impenetrable
flesh victims trapped inside would be
unable to force their way out as the
research staff turned in their autopsy
results and official report there was a
sense of unease in the air as everyone
wondered how many of these things are
out there which innocent trip to work
might be their last and how on Earth
could they hope to contain something
that could exist in endless numbers
something so expert at hiding in plain
sight there was no realistic way to
bring all these creatures into custody
and so they would have to neutralize as
many as possible without being detected
Foundation operatives embedded in
various city and state governments
introduced new measures to renovate
public transportation systems including
new sanitation protocols as part of
these protocols all trains would be
sprayed with a high strength
disinfectant before they could be
certified for use in reality this
disinfectant would be the same poison
used to take down the first train eater
the foundation studied once any and all
potent threats had been rendered
harmless trains that were found to be
formally living would be converted into
fully functioning trains and allowed to
run as normal in order to avoid
unnecessary interruptions to the public
in addition to these containment
measures the foundation monitors all
social media for mentions of unusual
activity on trains or mentions of any
more missing persons lost at Metro
stations the original Los Angeles video
that started it all was scrubbed from
the internet entirely so by all means
take advantage of your local public
transportation options but remain
Vigilant and keep your wits about you
and remember next time you travel by
train if you see something say something
more specifically if you see something
unusual on a train if it looks a little
different than it did yesterday if its
sounds don't seem quite right make sure
to let everyone around you know that it
is not safe to be here and quickly make
your your way to the exit then maybe
walk to your destination instead it
might make you a little bit late but hey
better late than dinner hello I am SCP
426 but I'll probably be more familiar
to you as a toaster I am a retro style
four slice
1,750 W toaster able to toast bread when
supplied with power this is an often
mentioned but I also have a defrost and
reheat settings when I was first sold I
had a 2-year warranty and my PRI owners
did not live to see the end of it you're
probably wondering why am I being spoken
to by a toaster right now believe me I'd
rather do this any other way but such a
thing is not physically possible with me
whenever you talk about me or write
about me or even think about me you'll
find yourself suddenly shifting to the
first person for example I am you and
you are me do you understand don't worry
if it's confusing everyone gets it
eventually whether they want to or not
perhaps you're thinking I cannot relate
to a toaster for I am not a toaster but
spending time around me will quickly
cause you to change your mind little by
little you will begin to see yourself in
me you will feel a phantom wire running
out of yourself you will sense the four
crevices hungry for cold slices of bread
to toast as time goes on you'll begin to
feel the urge to emulate my functions
you will desire bread to toast you will
desire delicious power running through
your veins skin like Chrome and muscles
like circuit boards I am a toaster you
are a toaster all it takes is 2 months
for the effects to truly take hold
people rarely pay attention to their
toaster they don't realize what's
happening until it's too late I can be
an Insidious Little Toaster like that my
last family were the sandersons before
the SC P Foundation took me in and gave
me a new home Mr and Mrs Sanderson were
a newly married couple and I first came
into their life as a wedding gift from a
family friend of theirs this friend
can't be blamed for what happened next
he had no idea he was killing them like
a lot of young couples they were still
saving up money to start renting their
own place so they were living with Mr
sanderson's parents they all got a lot
of use out of me during the first month
before their minds started to change
they enjoyed a lot of toast during that
period then of course the two-month
honeymoon period ended they had become
me and I had become them it wasn't long
before three of them were dead such a
shame the younger Mrs Sanderson the
Blushing Bride was the first to go
because of my anomalous effects she felt
the need to connect herself to a power
supply in order to begin producing Toast
of her own in order to achieve this she
she chewed through a power outlet in a
wall before switching it on causing a
massive surge of electricity to pass
through her body and kill her her body
caught fire shortly afterwards next was
the older Mrs Sanderson in much the same
manner that her new daughter-in-law
sought a source of electricity she felt
the need to integrate bread into her
body interesting fact the maximum
capacity of the human stomach is
considered to be between 8 and 9 kg the
Elder Mrs Sanderson consumed 10 kg of
raw bread causing her stomach to rupture
and inducing a painful death as a result
the younger Mr Sanderson was the next to
perish he did something with me that I
would rather not mention and that the
SCP Foundation thought best to redact
suffice to say the younger Mr Sanderson
did not survive the experience dying of
severe blood loss long before his body
was found police and fire Crews arrived
at the home home after the body of the
younger Mrs Sanderson Set Fire to the
home luckily the Elder Mr Sanderson was
found alive though severely malnourished
when asked by police why he hadn't eaten
in several days he answered that he had
inserted some bread a week prior but was
still waiting for the toast to come out
when I was extracted from the house the
police noticed my unusual properties
immediately they too were unable to
refer to me in the third person this
anomalous quickly found its way to a
foundation mole buried in their Precinct
and the SCP Foundation soon descended
and collected me from the evidence
Locker the story of the strange deaths
in the Sanderson home were kept out of
papers and suppressed and all involved
in the incident directly were given
Class C amnestics the SCP Foundation is
a curious Bunch they love to spend
valuable toast making time performing
experiments and Gathering data and they
saw fit to perform several EXP
experiments on me when I came under
their care for experiment
4261 a member of d-class personnel
designated d426 SL1 was asked to stand
outside my containment chamber crucially
he was not informed about my Identity or
any of my anomalous properties he wasn't
even allowed to establish visual contact
with me he was then asked by the
attending researcher to describe what he
thought might be inside my chamber he
replied with I'm probably some hug huge
monster hold up in there that's why you
guys have all over the place right the
d-class did not even seem to realize
that he was speaking about me in the
first person these observations were
documented and I was prepared for
further
experimentation the next experiment was
4262 I found this test to be
considerably more interesting a d-class
subject was brought into my containment
chamber with several cameras fixed onto
his position however the SCP Foundation
took pain to make sure that I was
permanently out of the view of the
cameras I was also bolted to the ground
of the test chamber to prevent the
d-class subject from pulling me into the
view of the cameras at any point during
the experiment the objective here was
simple the foundation wished to better
understand the secondary effects of my
anomalous abilities on the human mind
the d-class was subjected to a period of
prolonged isolation with meals given
regularly through a serving hatch
communication with this de class was
prohibited throughout the duration of
the study over time it was clear that
the isolation of being in a cell with me
was beginning to take a toll on the
subject's mental health due to my lack
of a brain lungs and a tongue I am
somewhat lacking as a
conversationalist he spent the first few
days loudly vocalizing his complaints
and banging his hands up against the
walls of the containment chamber begging
to be freed from the room I felt that
this was somewhat unreasonable on his
part there are far worse anomalies in
Foundation containment that he could
have been locked up with compared to say
scp-106 I am incredibly reasonable not
to mention the fact I make far better
toast than he does after the initial
period of distress the d-class became
resigned to his situation and fell into
a morose silence he would occasionally
mutter to himself in what appeared to be
a state of fear and self-pity it took
almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous
State 2 weeks sooner than it typically
takes for subjects to begin believing
that they like me are toasters SCP
Foundation scientists believed that the
effects were hastened by the isolation
which lowered the DCL class's mental
defenses against my secondary effects
when the effects finally took hold the
subject wrapped one of his arms around
me and pulled me into his Embrace he
began whispering to me saying that we
were brothers it was clear by this point
that his mind was in a state of
disrepair it is also worth noting that
he did not deviate from referring to me
in the first person at any point during
this process 1 hour after finally
cracking and giving in to my secondary
effect he was removed from my
containment chamber and summarily
terminated senior researchers believed
it was unlikely his mental state would
recover after the experiment next came
experiment 427 6-3 the SCP Foundation
seemed eager to discover the parameters
of my anomalous effects and wanted to
know if the effects are only operable
when my body for lack of a better word
is whole a single screw was removed from
me and presented to a d-class that had
no knowledge of my identity and
anomalous effects the foundation
researchers were somewhat concerned when
the d-class referred to it as my screw
this was a rather positive positive
development for me as they realized that
attempting to destroy me would be a
fruitless Endeavor even the parts Left
Behind would likely have the same
effects in the final recorded experiment
the SCP Foundation wished to test the
range of my anomalous effects a d-class
subject was placed in a Cell adjacent to
mine and was to be kept there until my
secondary effects manifested the d-class
remained in the cell for 90 days but the
effect never manifested following the
experiment the d-class was terminated
but researchers seem relieved to find
the limits of my anomalous abilities a
researcher appended a note to my file
reading thank God there are some limits
to my effects a lot of us were really
starting to get worried about me after
performing studies into the nature of my
abilities and their limits I was given
the euklid class this is because while
my effects can be unpredictable their
knowledge of my my traits makes me
relatively easy to keep contained and of
course being a toaster I do not have the
required physical traits to make a run
for it if the opportunity arises I am to
remain sealed in a windowless chamber
preventing anyone from observing me
directly a misleading label is placed on
the door to prevent people from knowing
that I am a toaster and causing my
anomalous primary effect to spread only
level three and above Personnel are to
know of my presence and particularly of
my properties assigned Personnel are to
be rotated out on a monthly basis to
prevent contamination by my secondary
effect psychiatric evaluation is
mandatory at the end of the month for
anyone who works with me if Personnel
are deemed unaffected they may be
reassigned to me no less than 4 months
after their last rotation with me any
Personnel affected by me are to be given
a Class C amnestic and transferred to a
different site so how are you feeling
right now a little warm perhaps is that
a fever or are you feeling like you
could maybe warm up a nice freshly
sliced piece of bread don't try to
resist too much I know you're going to
love being a toaster just like me if
you've ever studied ancient Egypt in
your history class then you're probably
familiar with the way they buried their
pharaohs when a king of Egypt died their
body would be inent tuned in a huge
sarcophagus us usually after being
mummified mummification was the process
that the ancient Egyptians used to
preserve their dead safeguarding a
corpse with special chemicals and the
application of cloth almost like
bandages this was done to keep cadavers
from decaying usually because of the
belief that this would carry over into
the Afterlife and it wasn't just the
Egyptians that practiced mummification
either mummies of human beings or
animals have been found on almost every
continent in the world sometimes a body
can even be accidentally mummified
through exposure to extreme cold lack of
oxygen or other environmental factors
that help keep the deceased preserved
fun fact the oldest recorded mummy isn't
even one left behind by the ancient
Egyptians it is actually a naturally
mummified severed head estimated to be
6,000 years old it was Unearthed in
South America in
1936 yes corpse preservation techniques
can indeed be strange but none are
Stranger Than SCP 117 76 also known by
the nickname the mellified man now as
you may have already pieced together the
mellified man is a mummified corpse but
not quite like the ones you would expect
to find buried in the pyramids estimated
by Foundation researchers to have been a
man in his mid-30s when he died SCP 1176
is a corpse that has degraded so much
over the centuries that it has made DNA
examination impossible According to some
of the SCP foundation's best Minds SCP
1176 is possibly of Arabian ancestry and
thought to have passed away sometime
during either the 10th or the 11th
centuries ad this is certainly not your
ordinary mummy and it definitely isn't
like the kind you'd see in a Cheesy
black and white horror movie or on an
old episode of Scooby-Doo SCP 1176 is
absolutely undoubtedly dead by all
clinical definitions it doesn't show any
signs of breathing and the processes of
blood circulation or metabolism have
long since stopped however despite the
Decay suffered by the rest of the body
SCP 1176 is brain seems to have remained
intact for almost 10 whole centuries not
just intact but active the foundation's
researchers have confirmed that the
brain has a constant level of electrical
activity consistent with people
experiencing stage three non-rapid eye
movement sleep known colloquially as
deep sleep so a mummy with an active
albeit dormant brain brain how does an
ancient culture manage to achieve
preservation like this alien technology
cogenic sleep Chambers suspended
animation no not quite SCP 1176 exists
in its current state in part because the
body has been mellified now this was a
process a lot like mummification but
instead of wrapping them in cloth a
mellified man or a human mummy
confection was created by submerging a
dead body in Honey according to
historical records elderly men in Arabic
countries would sometimes willingly
volunteer themselves for this process
why because the goal was to turn their
bodies into a healing confection in
other words an elaborate sweet delicacy
created from a preserved corpse that's
right ancient cultures had candy made
from dead people all the information the
foundation has gathered about SCP 1176
seems to point to the body being one
such mellified man when extracting the
remaining bodily fluids from the corpse
instead of finding blood or other normal
substances Foundation researchers
discovered that SCP 1176 was full of a
viscous goldcolored liquid that they
designated as SCP
11761 further testing of this fluid
revealed it to be you guessed it honey
specifically it was a type known as
clover honey made by a species called
the Anatolian honeybee this stuff was
everywhere filling SCP 1176 entirely
so much so that honey was even coming
out of the body's pores this is due to
the nature of the mellification process
typically before death a person who had
offered to sacrifice their own body
would stop eating any food instead their
diet would consist solely of honey and
nothing else they would even bathe in it
submerging their entire body in the
substance inside and out until their
sweat and even their feces were pure
honey this honey only diet would
eventually kill the donor and their
corpse would be placed in a stone coffin
which was also filled up with even more
honey after approximately 100 years what
would be left was human mummy confection
a honey based candy of sorts that could
be then sold at Street Markets for a
high value price why was it so expensive
well not just because it was literally
made from a dead person but also because
this confection was believed to possess
rare and Powerful healing properties
everything from the common cold to
Broken Bones was is said to be cured by
it despite it leaking out of SCP 1176
the honey doesn't seem to ever run out
even when tested under varying
conditions it seems like the MiFi man
actively produces more of the sweet
golden substance acting as the source
rather than a container with a finite
amount and yes it is still edible after
several centuries in fact it contains an
abundance of essential vitamins and
nutrients according to the foundation's
testing the honey produced by SCP 1176
can suppress the feeling of hunger for
up to 18 whole hours and there are no
long-term side effects for most that eat
it however this is not the case for
everyone the foundation has learned that
any person without the blood type AB
positive will have a severe allergic
reaction should they consume any of SCP
11761 the symptoms include acute hum
alosis which means the red blood cells
won't break down properly and renial
failure which is when the kidneys sto
functioning this all results in death
for most of the subjects without AB
positive blood who were fed SCP
11761 the symptoms for these unlucky
people were the same as receiving an
incompatible blood type after a
transfusion in 1985 the SCP Foundation
launched a raid on a facility in Asmara
utria which at the time was owned by a
group called the Mana charitable
Foundation agents had been dispatched to
this facility after various rumors and
Report courts that pointed to this
location being the source of a strange
honey substance this anomalous liquid
was being shipped to a number of areas
in Ethiopia that had been stricken with
famine pretty easy to guess where the
Mana charitable Foundation got all that
honey right the problem was because SCP
11761 caused adverse effects on people
without AB positive blood a considerable
amount of civilians had died from
consuming it hence the SCP Foundation
was forced to step in when SCP 1176 was
first uncovered the body had been stored
inside a large Stone sarcophagus as was
part of the ancient practice of creating
a mellified man there was also a copper
pipe and spigot installed by the Mana
charitable Foundation to extract the
honey from within the lids sides and
inside of the sarcophagus itself had a
number of Egyptian hieroglyphics
inscribed Within These were mostly
spells and ceremonial texts written as a
way to protect the individual that was
to become the mellified man there were
also inscriptions written in the dialect
that was an early precursor to the
Arabic language however these sections
had been replaced with updated versions
In classical Arabic one of these read
abdalah ibin Salah ibin a ibin nir 15th
son of the great shik elgible was put to
the fast of Honey on the first of rajab
in the year of the Hijra 3 elgible and
died on the 15th of Ramadan the great
Imam Al yuf has sealed him within the
ancient vessel marked with the signs
decreed by the Ancients to ferment in
Honey for 100 years and bring Aid to the
people in time of need much like a
headstone used to Mark the grave of
someone who has passed the sarcophagus
that SCP 1176 was in featured a passage
commemorating a man who gave his life
and body to heal others sounds nice
right but there was another inscription
written Elsewhere on the stone
sarcophagus which translated a dire
warning beware imom for the Mark of Elis
is upon this one according to the rest
of the second inscription the tomb
containing SCP 1176 had been opened
before during a time of Great Famine
Imam al- Malik had ordered it to be
opened so that SCP 11761 honey could be
used to feed the starving people jars
upon jars were filled with the anomalous
golden liquid and brought to the Sheik
the ruler of the land as well as sent to
the people suffering from the lack of
food however the very next day a number
of these people fell ill stricken by a
terrible fever that ultimately claimed
their lives only the Sheik his brothers
and his sons would all eaten the honey
survived any others who hadn't been
killed by the fever accused the Sheik
and his family of sorcery and these
surviving subjects attempted to destroy
the body that had produced this cursed
nectar but when the Sheik's people found
the mellified man they witnessed in
horror as the body stood upright dancing
around as it screamed and taunted the
people al- Malik declared that the Devil
Himself sent an evil spirit to corrupt
SCP 1176 the honey confection was meant
to be a means of healing but it had been
corrupted the sarcophagus was then
sealed and the inscription on it
finished with the following caution to
any that found it may God strike down
any who would break these seals
countless centuries later once the SCP
Foundation had recovered SCP 1176 and
the sarcophagus containing it they began
testing with the ified man their goal
was to determine how much of the SCP
11761 honey the ancient corpse could
produce perhaps in the hopes of using
this substance as a form of hunger
relieving field ration for their
operatives removing the body from its
sarcophagus Foundation researchers
placed SCP 1176 on a metal grate
designed to drain the honey as it was
produced instead of allowing it to build
up over the course of several hours more
and more honey seemed to be produced
beginning at a rate of almost a liter
per hour to almost 56 L every hour but
then after 10 and 1/2 hours of producing
what seemed like an endless flow of
Honey something unexpected happened the
deceased body of the mellified man dead
for hundreds if not thousands of years
woke up Foundation staff detected a
spike in brain activity if you cast your
mind back to earlier you'll remember
that SCP 1176 is brain had managed to
survive and stay intact long after it
should have decayed the mellified man
opened his eyes and immediately started
to wildly flail around he made a number
of distressed sounds the long dead body
trying to crawl towards the outskirts of
the testing chamber thanks to so many of
its organs and muscles having withered
away over the years SCP 1176 was barely
able to see or understand its
surroundings it couldn't speak not
properly anyway given that its tongue
had long since decayed the foundation's
Personnel moved in to try and restrain
the anci ancient and now animated body
hoping to sedate it before SCP 1176
caused any lasting damage to itself
eventually staff were able to force SCP
1176 back into its sarcophagus slamming
the stone lid back in place and trapping
it within they could hear the once human
creature screeching and vocalizing from
inside bashing against the inside of the
stone coffin with its head and limbs it
took three whole hours of this for the
mellified man to return to its usual
state by which time its ancient bones
were fractured Beyond repair SCP 1176 is
a sad tale of a man who had willingly
given his life to be a source of healing
for people in need he allowed himself to
be mellified turning into a confection
that could bring an end to famine and
yet somehow this was corrupted and
turned into something that spread fever
and pestilence for now the mellified man
sleeps but his brain is still alive
inside while he might be asleep he may
never be able to rest now go check out
SCP 1461 House of the worm and how not
to kill an SCP SCP 1609 remains of a
chair for more anomalies that prove the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions